so typically when there's a conspiracy
theory it takes a few months maybe a
couple years before it turns out that it
was true the media will debunk it
they'll claim they'll say it's debunked
and the story is fake so Russell Brand
gets uh kicked off all these TV shows
they remove all his content he gets
accused of serious impropriety is one
way to put it and then YouTube
demonetizes his channel even though he
didn't break any rules and there are a
lot of people saying I think there's an
agenda against Russell Brand for some
reason some people are citing this uh
interview that he had on Bill Maher
where he's talking about big
pharmaceutical companies and uh I think
this is the fastest a conspiracy theory
has been proven true because we now have
Rumble releasing a letter from the UK
government trying to get Russell Brand
demonetized on Rumble we also have a
letter that was sent to tick tock as
well so let me just put it simply the UK
government is trying to strip the
finance like the money from Russell
Brand oh so can conspiracy confirmed
well geez that was fast wow I thought
that was going to take a few you know
they'd cancel him we'd forget all about
it two years ago by and they'd be like
oh by the way that was us we'd be like
oh well the government really did go
after him in that way no we got that
story we'll talk about it we got Ray
Epps pleading guilty we got big breaking
news an emergency Declaration of Eagle
Pass Texas because thousands of migrants
are storming into the country and guess
what the emergency declaration it's not
to stop the illegal immigrants it's to
help them the emergency declaration gets
them extra funding so they can assist
these individuals as they illegally
enter the country we'll talk about all
that before we get started my friends
head over to timcast.com click timcast
IRL X Miami to pick up your tickets to
timcast IRL live in Miami October 6th at
6 pm to 10 30 p.m we've got Patrick Bet
David James O'Keefe Matt Gates and
lukakowski originally we had Donald
Trump Jr there's been a scheduling
conflict unfortunately he's not gonna be
able to make it and uh you know it is
what it is so I apologize to everybody
who's really looking forward to seeing
them there's nothing we can do you know
is the president's son seems like he's
probably really busy right now but James
O'Keefe will be there Alex Stein will be
doing a set just before the show Michael
Seifert from Public Square will be
speaking before as well with Hannah
Claire and Josie the redheaded
libertarian there are going to be many
more special guests at this event it's
gonna be a really really awesome super
excited uh to be doing this and I hope
to see you all there for elite members
at timcast is going to be a meet-up and
uh I guess we call it supper it's not
dinner it's 3 P.M but this is going to
be for elite members only uh on October
6. also click join us to support our
work directly and get access to
uncensored members only shows we're
gonna have an uncensored show coming up
for you at 10 p.m tonight just after we
wrap the uh the main live show and as a
member you get access to our Discord
server as well where you will hang out
with like-minded individuals who host a
pre-show they post they they host an
after after show so really come on in
join uh the membership hang out with
people build community work on stuff
meet people make connections that's what
it's all about smash that like button if
you haven't already subscribe to this
channel if you haven't already and share
this show with your friends that's the
best way you can help we got two awesome
guests joining us tonight we have
Harrison Smith hello who are you what do
you do I'm Harrison Smith I host the
American journal on infowars.com it's
the morning show the lead into Alex
Jones so we're at awards.com band.video
right on thanks for thanks for hanging
out we got Chef gruel is here as well
all right good time Chef Andrew gruel
I'm America's chef owner of
americangravy.com and everything food
related and uh it was actually just uh
Good Fortune uh Chef girls out here to
help us with our idea for building
physical parallel economic brick and
mortar stores we're talking about this
anti-time Square so uh you know you guys
were watching we had Terence Williams
and he's like we need chef girl and I'm
like we'll bring them out here and so
here he is and we were talking earlier
really excited maybe we'll get into a
little bit about you know what we hope
to accomplish but uh should be fun
thanks for hanging out man thanks for
having me we got Phil hello I am
filiponte lead singer of all the remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
what's up Carter what's up Phil I'm uh
Carter usually I'm in my studio making
music but today I'm filming for Surge
and let's get into it here's the first
story from the post-millennial ladies
and gentlemen the conspiracy theory has
been proven true in what is this five
days
it's like it's like five days since they
accused Russell Brand and started going
after all of his financials trying to
get him banned from everything and then
you get NBC and a bunch of these Outlets
saying conspiracy theorists think that
there's an agenda against Russell Brand
and then a few days later UK Parliament
sends letters to social media platforms
demanding demonetization would it say
demonization is that demonization
yeah come on come on come on post
millennial I always make one of them
demonetization of Russell Brand but I
guess demonization works too it's
similar demonization although it may be
politically correct and socially easier
for rumble to join a cancel culture mob
doing so would be a violation of our
company's values and Mission so we have
this tweet from Mario novel
the the uh this is the culture media and
Sports Committee of the House of Commons
sent a letter to tick tock saying while
we recognize Tick Tock is not the
creator of the content published by Mr
brand and his content may be within the
community guidelines set up by the
platforms we are concerned that he may
be able to profit from his content on
the platforms holy what dude confirmed
conspiracy against Russell Brent I'm
just really excited for this we have a
very quick confirmation of a government
conspiracy against Russell Brand wait
hold on here's the rumble tweet because
Rumble is awesome they they of course
released this with a statement saying
today we received an extremely
disturbing letter from a committee chair
in the UK Parliament while Rumble
obviously deplores sexual assault rape
in all serious crimes and believes that
both alleged victims and the accused are
entitled to full and serious
investigation it is vital to note that
the recent allegations against Russell
Brand have nothing to do with content on
rumble's platform just yesterday YouTube
announced that based solely on these
media accusations it was barring Mr bran
from monetizing his video content Rumble
stands for very different values we have
devoted ourselves to the vital cause of
Defending a free internet meaning an
internet where no one arbitrarily
dictates which ideas can or cannot be
heard or which citizens may or may not
be entitled to a platform we regard it
as deeply inappropriate and dangerous
the UK Parliament would attempt to
control who was allowed to speak on our
platform or to earn a living from doing
so singling on an individual and
demanding his ban is even more
disturbing given the absence of any
connection between the allegations and
his content on Rumble we don't agree
with the behavior of many Rumble
creators but we refuse to penalize them
for actions that have nothing to do with
our platform although it may be
politically and socially easier for
rumble to join a cancel culture mob
doing so would be a violation of our
company's values and Mission we
emphatically reject the UK parliament's
demands and and here we have this letter
to Chris Chris pavlovsky the CEO of
Rumble saying I am writing concerning
the serious allegations regarding
Russell Brand the contact in the context
of his being an accountant produce arm
Rumble with more than 1.4 million
followers the culture media and Sports
Committee is Raising questions with the
broadcasters and production companies
who previously employed Mr brand to
examine both the culture of the industry
in the past and whether that culture
still prevails today that is to say they
have outright admitted the UK government
is reaching out to other networks asking
them to remove Russell Russell Brand and
take away his income because he was
accused
allegations from a decade to two decades
ago this is amazing
they say they said we are also looking
at use of social media including on
Rumble where he issued his preemptive
response to the accusations made against
him by the Sunday Times in Channel 4
dispatches while we recognize that
Rumble is not the creator of the content
published by Mr brand we are concerned
that he may be able to profit from his
content on the platform think about what
they're saying right here the UK
government is outright saying if you
commit any crime ever you should not be
allowed to live
at all what does Russell Brand do for a
living he's a personality he's an actor
he communicates he talks they take his
shows down they try to take his podcast
down YouTube actually demonetizes his
show they're basically saying he should
not be allowed to make a living anymore
for any reason even though he's never
been convicted of a crime or I should
say I don't know if he's been kicked of
any crime but in this instance he's only
been accused well he hasn't even been
accused on a criminal level right it was
just the article that came out I mean
it's a pure there is an investigation
but because of the article right right
right right so and it seems like
especially with things like YouTube it
seems like that I mean we're in the age
of the open conspiracy essentially at
this point where YouTube is saying
they're going man we really wish we
could kick Russell Brand off but we
can't just do it outright if only if
somebody came out with an article nudge
nudge hint hint and so they're just
working in this almost reciprocal way
and I mean you know Rumble says we're
fighting for free speech on the internet
that age is rapidly ending we have the
EU Digital Services act the UK
Parliament just passed the uh what is it
the Online safety bill which ironically
when it was in draft form was presided
over by the same woman that sent this
letter Carolina denigi or whatever her
name is so yeah it's it's coming to an
end pretty rapidly this whole uh free
speech thing we've been enjoying so long
well I mean this is the UK I I think
we're actually we have to remain
steadfast but I think we're doing a
really good job in the U.S as it
pertains to the boycotts and the
boycotts the fact that Rumble exists
shows that we have started to push back
and we are gaining ground
Russell Brand they can't take away his
money because Rumble said no everyone
else bends the knee but I love the
precedent set by YouTube so what now all
anyone has to do to terminate someone's
account is just accuse them or have
someone accuse them I mean this is all
all awful uh sufficiently horrifying for
me to be like all right we need to
completely isolate uh social media from
governments this is something that we've
been aware of or we the Twitter files
have shown that there are governments
interested in accessing the power and
influence that comes from social media
to think that you know other governments
aren't doing it with you know just
because the U.S has has been exposed and
they're supposed to be efforts being
undertaken to to prevent it doesn't mean
that other countries aren't going to try
to apply the same pressure and it's for
essentially the same things they're
looking to end the Liberty to speak your
mind and say things that are
controversial you've got that Jacinda I
forget what her last name is the prime
minister of New Zealand specifically
coming out and saying things that 15
years ago if you said publicly you'd
have gotten excoriated for it you would
have been you would have been thrown
right into the bin with Stalin Hitler
and all the other authoritarians Paul
pot whatever all of them and and now
it's looked at as something that people
have become so numb to the efforts at
limiting what you're allowed to say and
what you can't say that that these kinds
of behaviors from governments you know
only the the alternative media seems to
take issue with it and it's a big
problem and obviously we're all pretty
much here in agreement and it's I'm
thankful that that Rumble did what they
did
but this speaks to the attitude of
governments and it's not just the United
States government it's governments
across the western western world
yeah I just don't I don't think social
media I don't think this is uh an
imposition on social media I think
social media is uh happy to go along
with it actually happy to have the
excuse to ban the people that they
wanted to ban in the first place I agree
100 and the reason there are people that
are out there that are going to say oh
you know it's because of money it's not
because of money it's because of access
because if they do what the government
wants then the government becomes
friendly with them and that's power it's
beyond money because Google doesn't need
money well you know it's also it is
access to a certain degree there's also
fear sure if you're if you're a a
company say you're an email service
provider or maybe you're a tech company
and uh some guys in black suits show up
to your office and they start going like
listen here you know we uh need your
help taking out the uh terrorists if you
know what I'm saying otherwise things
could get messy for you it's funny
basically what they do yeah and that's
almost exactly the tone of that letter
that they send because they don't say
demonetize Russell Brand they say we're
awful can concerned that he may be
making money you would hate to have that
on your conscience wouldn't you yeah
it's it's a mafia style Shakedown
absolutely how long before they shut
Rumble down that's the question or
attempt to obviously Rumble you know I
think back to parlor remember what
happened with parlor thank God Rumble
has built the infrastructure necessary
to be able to broadcast him how long
before they attempt in some capacity
because now it's Rumble and perhaps
Twitter against the government I don't
want to make the joke that I that I need
to make so I'm I just can't I can't but
let's just say that there are a series
of attempts to assassinate the
characters of key individuals who are
playing vital roles and it seems like
their only strategy with now Tim Ballard
is being accused it's like here's a guy
who's married has nine kids and they're
like oh look it was him too and it's
just like oh come on like Russell Brand
you have people being like well he was a
promiscuous guy I mean man this could be
true I hope it's not and then you have
people they're accusing Tim Ballard and
it's like oh come on yeah like the dude
who's Halfway Around the World hunting
down child traffickers had time to go
and get out of here with this stuff but
then you got Howard Stern out there
saying the most outlandish things and he
can't get canceled he even said today it
was the headline I am woke yeah I am
woke I mean that's he literally just he
might as well have said please don't
cancel me I will lay down and I will
kiss the boot I will put the whole soul
right in my mouth he I mean it is it is
embarrassing but when you have the
history that Howard Stern says you're
left with few options because all it
takes is someone getting a uh their hair
a hair across their ass and they're
going to come after you and you have
just more evidence than you could ever
possibly deflect from here's the best
thing about Rumble Rumble has a payment
processor they have their own servers
they have their own hosting
they are building out everything they
need so that they cannot remove them now
what they did with uh parlor was a
coordinated uh blocking of it from a
bunch of different app stores these
tactics aren't working
it worked for parlor sure and then
Rumble pops up everyone learned what
happened because everyone knew that
Amazon you know messed with their uh
their their servers or whatever they
shut down parlor on false reasons they
basically said that January Sixers were
using it whatever and it's like they
used Facebook more than they used part
of course and then Elon Musk buys
Twitter and turns it into X and they're
freaking out screaming and just losing I
look you know shout out to Elon Musk for
buying the platform and and building it
now they're running this I don't know if
you guys saw this lie that Elon Musk
wants to charge all users which was not
what happened and they're using that to
just like they are spreading this
propaganda because they're trying to get
people to leave Twitter so they can
regain control of the narrative the real
story was that Elon said something the
effect of the only way to deal with all
the Bots would be if you were to charge
everyone like a small fee which you know
we're trying to figure out how to deal
with and they're like aha he says he's
gonna charge everybody money and then
Elon comes out and he's like I'm not
saying we're going to charge everyone
money I'm saying that is how you get rid
of bots but of course the media runs the
narrative and then a bunch of people
sign up for blue sky or whatever because
they're trying to regain control they're
losing and they're also launching
investigations into Tesla and SpaceX and
I mean it you know they go after you
however they can and obviously what it's
about is that they want a total control
of the information flow because that is
in this information age that's how you
control people you control what goes
into their mind like some sort of
information War right it's it's crazy
let's let's let's uh let's talk about
how evil these people let's let's jump
to this story first I had another story
I was going to jump to we'll talk about
this one from the post millennial Tim
Ballard speaks out against false
allegations leveled at him after
announcing potential Senate run I will
not stop I will not give up
and Wednesday Tim Ballard released a
statement addressing allegations leveled
against him following his announcement
that he was running for the senate in
Utah Ballard read from a press release
from his non-profit the spear fund which
read rescuing kids and fighting child
trafficking is an ugly and dark business
especially when as the result of my work
for more than 20 years we continue to
expose members of the powerful
well-funded child trafficking cartels
evil pedophiles will stop at nothing and
they have allies in government in the
media in big corporations and even in
public institutions they will continue
to lie about an attempt to destroy my
good name and they will never stop
Ballard said he wanted to let everyone
know that I I and our vast Army of
supporters will likewise never stop we
will keep fighting for the vulnerable
all over the globe and we know that the
truth will always Prevail I am a
faithful member in good standing in the
Church of Jesus Christ of Latter-day
Saints I believe in Jesus Christ the
holy scriptures and I believe in our
faith with my whole heart that will
never change Ballard said that it has
been alleged that an anonymous LDS
spokesperson issued a statement about me
through a tabloid that is often hostile
to people of Faith further my church is
not publicly verified as authenticity so
uh we have this other story from the
post-millennial Utah D.A closed criminal
investigation into operation Underground
Railroad Tim Ballard in March they're
false allegations what do you think is
going to happen if you're if you're
hunting down trafficking cartels
yeah they're going to play dirty to try
and stop you the funny thing about this
the attacks against Russell Brand the
attacks against Julian Assange and now
get this Rudy Giuliani
oh that's just come on it's just the
only thing they have is they're like how
do we stop this guy just say he groped
some woman or something and it's like
okay I guess yeah we're at the point
where it's like dude
like I was saying earlier you come at
Russell Brand and we're like that's kind
of weird they're all coming after
Russell Brand
but he does have that pass that was this
thing he joked a lot about this stuff
you know he there's a video Someone
posted where he's joking with a woman if
he can get on with her or her daughters
and she's like my daughters are 15 or
whatever
he made some pretty crude jokes and so
you Wonder Man how responsible or
irresponsible was this guy but Tim
Ballard like a a
Bible thumping uh child trafficking uh
hunt like hunting
is what I'm sorry the least credible
allegations I've ever heard are the ones
against Tim Ballard it's just there's no
way I'm I'm I just at this point
and they come out and claim that Donald
Trump did something it's just no one's
gonna believe it they could come out and
say Annie they could come out and say
Andrew Tate was like abusing women at
this point and I'm just like bro all of
this stuff to be fair they did come out
and said that about Tate I'm saying they
could they could ex like make crazier
accusations at this point I'm just like
and you take could literally come out
and say those past videos you know or
I'll all of him are saying these things
I'm not going to believe any of it it's
just they try every single person it's
the only thing they have yeah but the
thing is is that when Russell Brand he
was out in the public eye saying all of
these things and the media supported him
he was a hero of the media that's the
crazy thing right so the time in which
all these things were happening
everybody knew and his caricature right
his personality in a lot of these shows
was as that kind of gutter snipe like
misogynistic uh you know guy so and he
was the hero it wasn't until he then
crossed over that he became the enemy
they're like you know we tried calling
everybody racists for a while and didn't
really work so we upgraded to white
supremacist
that's not really working anymore let's
just call them all rapists yeah and it's
it's you know sort of non-falsifiable
right you can't prove or disprove
something that happened 15 20 years ago
I don't know much about uh uh Tim
Ballard but uh you know Russell Brand I
mean that was the sort of character that
he was playing but sort of regardless of
all of that are are we saying that if
you get convicted of a crime you can't
earn a living anymore right uh which
obviously hasn't been convicted or as
far as I can tell even uh legally
charged with uh committing any any of
these crimes but it's almost like a uh
does the fun does the punishment fit the
crimes this not cruel and unusual
punishment for yeah
you know potentially baseless accusation
and the craziest part about that was the
article that came out in The Times They
say like these women didn't say anything
until we our reporters approached them
yeah and they thought it was important
to come out because of the his Newfound
prominence as a dissident right-wing
person so it's like they're not even
hiding anymore they're literally saying
because he is a prominent dissident and
because he speaks out against the
establishment therefore here's the
accusations that we're making against
him I think that that's that's super
important that the fact that this is all
coming out is only because of the
because of his political stances this
was perfect this was this was perfectly
fine no one had an issue there was no
problem for what almost 20 years now
that that since it's happened same thing
again we talked about Howard Stern
earlier no one has an issue with that
and no one's coming after Howard Stern
because Howard Stern is is uh pushing
the party line he is saying the
politically correct
positions he has the proper allowable
opinions if you have a dissenting
opinion there are people that are going
to go at go and go into your history
look for anything they can come up with
people love to tell me I'm wrong or
specifically like lips pardon my
French but like bad liberals people are
terrible liberals we are in a maoist
cultural revolution in the United States
right now these are the things that were
done in maoist China in order for the
Communist Party to gain control they use
the Red Guard to intimidate people to
accuse people of all sorts of different
in uh improprieties and stuff this is
what's going it's obviously it's not
going to look exactly the same as in
China you know 70 or 60 years ago but a
lot of the same tactics are being used
of the same shaming the same trying to
ostracize people kick them out of polite
Society take their ability to provide
for their families and stuff all of that
stuff is happening right now
what my question too is let's apply this
same logic Tara read that's all I got to
say tarot reading right Joe Biden's got
to be banned from YouTube yep no more
White House videos on YouTube because
Joe Biden you know he he did those awful
shut the Clinton Foundation down shut it
down yeah yeah that would only Bill
Clinton can't take a dime from anybody
remember that's what it is and it's it's
the great reset and it's the uh the
stakeholder capitalism is what it is
where they have companies I mean it's we
said the great reset should be called
like something like the great
consolidation or the the great
coagulation right it's it's uh companies
and government acting seemingly
independently but in perfect uh
coordination with one another to carry
these things out so I mean this is uh
it's it's a cultural revolution but it's
worldwide and it's being orchestrated
from it's being orchestrated from a
central power but also like we really
are in this in this phase where they all
just sort of know and there doesn't
necessarily have to be some sort of
conspiracy behind the scenes where
they're secretly communicating with one
another they all just sort sort of know
I mean you know in the old days you'd
have like a false flag attack you'd have
to control the median you'd have to have
the police on your side and every you
know certain people in key positions now
they just sort of do it and the media
knows okay here's the narrative that I'm
going along with and don't investigate
it too much or else you might find out
how fake it is it's because it's an
ideology you don't have to have you you
can have Christians from different parts
of the world that have never met each
other and they're still going to be able
to tell you how Christianity works you
can have Muslims from different parts of
the world that have never met each other
they're still going to be able to tell
you how Islam works it's the same thing
with this with this type of mentality
it's an ideology yeah and so it doesn't
matter if the people are read into the
newest Cutting Edge uh stuff in fact
sometimes they make errors like when uh
WebEx and wimixon was a bad bad one but
when kgenti Brown Jackson was uh uh yeah
the the when she was having a hearing
and she said I'm not a biologist like
that was the wrong answer now because he
was saying gender was biology exactly
she should it should have been uh I
forget I'm not a gender theorist yeah
that would have been the correct one she
actually made an error according to the
theory but like Tim said she should have
said she's a gender theorist to be able
to explain that but it you don't have to
know The Cutting Edge because they'll
cover for you if you make an error it
doesn't matter you're on you have the
right politics you're you're going for
the right side so we'll go ahead and
we'll we'll brush the the missed step
under the rook and simply put if you are
living your life living your career of
hunting down trafficking cartels the the
the ease is the most obviously way to
stop you is to accuse you is to try and
do something like this bunk allegations
but it's but I mean look how long until
Oliver Anthony gets falsely accused
I mean he's trying real hard not to be
super political despite the fact that
his songs are very political and
anti-establishment which is anti-left
inherently
it's only a matter of time I guess and
and you know the the real issue is what
they don't want you to do is have your
own platform to be able to defend
yourself I mean it's the same thing they
uh you know did with with Alex Jones
right they accuse him of things and then
remove him from social media so he can't
actually argue back so the only
narrative that's allowed to be
proliferated is their narrative so they
want and and the way that the
specifically like the online uh safety
act in the UK they want the companies
and the platforms themselves to
preemptively take action on content
that's posted so the way it is now if
the government issues a request and then
retroactively you go you go in and
remove it they want the companies to
actually take that burden on and remove
posts themselves preemptively before the
government has to get involved so that's
where the stakeholder capitalism comes
in where the corporations are actually
taking on that burden and if they don't
then the corporations are the ones being
punished by the uh by the government so
they want to create a situation where
they can make accusations and the
accused has no ability to respond in a
mainstream fashion let's talk about
Howard Stern for the New York Post
Howard Stern hits back at critics I am
woke mother effer and I love it
this is the perfect example I am so
grateful for Howard Stern because if
ever you want to explain to someone the
cult you need only show them Howard
Stern
he's uh he says I hear I hear that a lot
that I'm not good anymore because I'm
woke
by the way I kind of take that as a
compliment that I'm woke self-described
king of king of all media said on Monday
I'll tell you how I feel about it to me
the opposite of woke is being asleep
said Stern a staunch supporter of the
democratic party and if woke means I
can't get behind Trump which is what I
think it means or that I support people
who want to be transgender or I'm for
the vaccine dude call me woke as you uh
call me call me woke as you effing once
turn added
let me break it down for you you don't
have to support Donald Trump
to oppose wokeness
you you don't have to be I mean in fact
there are many people who oppose
wokeness who are trans who uh have
gotten the vaccine Howard Stern is the
perfect example of cult member
he's simply saying
I want money and I will suckle whatever
I need to suckle to get it a guy who now
look at this viral clips from uh 1999 I
think it was Columbine yeah where he was
saying I I'm not I can't even repeat
what he said yeah I'll try and keep it
as family friendly as possible Howard
Stern advocated for
the Columbine perpetrators
to have their way with their victims and
questioned why they wouldn't do it this
guy is as Despicable
as you can possibly imagine and he's
always been he's always been
so this is the funny thing right now
we're looking at everything he's saying
and being like what a spineless this is
his bit he always sides with evil
that's his thing well I mean but you
know he started off as being the the
Free Speech Warrior I mean I hate to
think that we're giving Howard Stern
what he wants right now because all he
wants is relevance he's not really
relevant anymore so this is his sort of
uh desperate grasp at being relevant
which you know really he's a drowning
man and now he's reaching up to pull
woke down with him which good riddance
uh because who wants to be associated
with someone like him I think he you
know he he actually explains what woke
is perfectly there he's like if you're
for the vaccine if you're for doing
whatever the powers tell you then that's
what I am no dude you know if if that's
what he is if that's what he was to have
said but he's not I mean wokeness is
being a part of the cult you can have
reasonable disagreements on being for or
against certain gender ideological
ideology things or the vaccine there are
a lot of intelligent people who are not
woke who have real conversations about
this Howard Stern is basically just
saying don't know don't care whatever
they tell me to say I'll say please give
me more money yeah and I mean the
Columbine thing is what everybody's
talking about right now you can go on
YouTube you can watch old Howard Stern
shows from the 90s I'm not I'm not a
like prudish person at all but some of
the things they were saying back then
like you know make make me go oh boy I
can't believe they sent me that back
then the Columbine thing yeah that's
that's really bad but in terms of like
racist and sex I mean he was pretty far
out there I mean if you you can find
hours of Howard Stern saying things that
would get him canceled and it's got a
whole movie about it private parts right
right if for some reason Howard Stern
hit his head and woke up a new person
tomorrow and he turned on this wokeness
he would be the next Target his show
would be canceled overnight yep and so
he's sitting in his in his studio and
I'm willing to bet someone came to him
and said hey man don't fly too close to
the Sun keep it keep it here you know
here's what we want and expect and he
was like you got a bus yeah just get and
get ahead of it too yup get ahead of it
say the right thing oh I mean the reason
why he's saying I'm woke I'm woke I'm
woke I swear I swear it's because all of
these clips are coming out which would
get anyone canceled well it's Uncle
Uncle Uncle right like he's getting his
arm twisted and he's throwing it out
there it's the Battle Cry I bet he cries
at night yeah I'm not kidding I'm I'm
not like I'm not trying to be like haha
what a loser I'm saying like I you can't
be a guy who has your whole career based
on saying racial slurs and sexually
inappropriate things now be literally on
your knees begging begging like a
pathetic spineless little baby and feel
good about yourself he's he's been
pretty he was pretty open in private
parts that he's kind of a cowardly guy
like he did he came out and said the
same like he's like oh you know I'm kind
of scared of that
um and I mean that's that just kind of
shows here like he doesn't have the the
courage to stand up and and look at the
powers that be in in the phase and say
no I'm not gonna just kiss the boot you
know
he says I want to be awake I want to
read legitimate news sources Stern also
alluded to claims made by Trump and his
supporters that President Biden's
victory was fraudulent here's how woke I
am I believe the election was not rigged
I am woke I think it's a compliment he
said it's like it's really weird that he
goes through a list of all of these
things saying please please I'm saying
the things I was told to say
I'm just imagining Howard Stern on his
knees crying as these like woke
20-something year old fat blue-haired
women are like say it or I'll get you
fired because we can email three people
and then he's just like please please
wow I just look man
I don't I could not understand
doing that we I talked about this before
when I was little
I'm like watching these historical
lessons or whatever in school or they
play cartoons
they tell stories about
someone would get captured and they
would say reject you or renounce your
faith otherwise we'll kill you and
they'd be like I will never do it and
then I'd be like why not just lie like
seriously just just say it and then
now I I wouldn't say I can I would
completely ever agree I do think there's
some value in just trying to escape
people who are attacking you and being
smart about it but now I get it to a
certain degree Howard Stern is the kind
of guy that would immediately fall to
his knees and offer to uh like if a guy
broke into his house
he'd just be like I will let you do
anything to my body I swear to God just
whatever you say man you can have you
can you can have anything including me
that's the kind of guy that he is
whereas like I'm sure most people listen
to this this show
uh me and many many people in this room
would not purport to be tough guys who
are going to want to fight but would
probably try to protect our homes to
whatever degree we could whereas Howard
Stern would just drop to his knees and
be like tell me what to do and I'll do
it
well it doesn't I mean has he left his
house yet I'm pretty sure he like went
into his basement when covid first
started and like didn't leave until like
maybe a couple months ago it's like oh
yeah yeah oh no it's it's like pathetic
I mean literally a couple months ago
there was a clip going around of him
like getting mad at his wife for like
going out do you know what I'm talking
about oh yeah I've seen that again yeah
yeah he he's he's a hypochondriac I mean
he is like still living in the heart of
covet um he he eats crustless sandwiches
because he doesn't want he thinks
there's bacteria on the crust
could you imagine like take this article
and bring it back in time to to you know
the the 90s when Howard Stern is like
this shock Jack that everyone's talking
about like wow he's so crazy and then be
like nah that's who he really is it's so
embarrassing you know it's kind of crazy
because Legacy matters what are you
alive for you're alive to leave
something behind for your family for
your friends for your kids to have a
positive impact that makes Humanity
better
jeez well I mean this is Rage Against
the Machine forcing people to get
vaccinated before they go to their shows
rage on behalf of the machine yeah yeah
and I mean yeah you know it's it it is
it's it it all goes back to a spiritual
battle and that's what that's what I get
from all of what we've just seen Howard
Stern say it's just this like
deep-seated really really like
really thorough spiritual cowardice
where he's gonna he's just like I just
believe whatever they tell me I believe
whatever they tell me I have no beliefs
higher than uh the humans around me who
order me around if Howard Stern was
sitting in a park eating a ham sandwich
and having a milkshake and a bunch of
trump supporters walked up to him and
they're like hey how are we gonna We
want to have a word with you he'll go I
I agree I love Trump
I've loved it the whole time I mean the
show is a show it's not real like you
guys know I
he will he will say anything I'm saying
you you could a guy in a Maga had could
walk up to him like hey how are nice to
meet you and he'll immediately be the
kind of guy who's like oh you know
Trump's actually really good I really
like him and the things in the show
aren't real just I'll say whatever I
need to say
spineless cowardice seems like sad
sad but this is so many people it's not
just Howard's turn right there are so
many people right now and I'm sure the
people listening know people like this
that you know like I'll put it this way
everybody's got their friend more than
one maybe or family member who you know
has said something bad or done something
offensive
and all of a sudden now they're acting
hoity-toity acting like you know oh
everyone's got to fall in line why
they're scared it'll come for them
I was talking to some people from Vice
and I was uh telling about this I was
like dude back when we were working
there like the articles that they were
writing and stuff that the stuff that
they were that was getting all the
traffic and and hitting like they won't
do any of that stuff and they're like
well we can't do that anymore and I'm
like says who who says you can't write
the articles that people actually want
to read hey guess what Vice is bankrupt
congratulations everybody you you had a
choice to march in lockstep with losers
like Howard Stern and then lose all your
money and that's what you chose that's
really amazing I really do Wonder I'd
love to have a conversation with Shane
Smith haven't talked to the guy in a
decade I really wonder about how he let
them take his creation the CNN of the
street the multi-billion dollar
Corporation grind it into a paste and
then crap it onto the floor
that's it I mean look when Vice was was
growing and expanding it was a big
threat to these to these corporations
they all wanted a piece because they
didn't want to get left behind what do
they do instead infiltrate destroy and
it's gone
yeah I don't know if they did that on
purpose or if it's just like an
inevitable consequence of uh being their
form of of woke or whatever you want to
call it well for advice it was because
they had a series of uh allegations
against so this is what I was I'm gonna
be very careful I was told this this is
true by uh people who were high up and
had been the company for a very long
time that there were a series of
accusations made against uh prominent
employees some of this is widely
reported just Google search it you can
read it and the investors came in and
said the only way to deal with these
accusations and to not lose our deals
our contracts our sponsors and violent
morality Clauses is to become feminist
embrace the feminism become a champion
of the activism and push back on
misogyny and now you are protecting
yourself and they went you got it boss
and then just spiraled Into Obscurity
and weren't they and wasn't the main
investor George Soros or Soros
controlled uh organization uh no no uh
Vice first got their big money from I
think it might have been Fox no it's not
fair they when they came I used to know
it's been so long you know I thought it
was Disney and so and that was way later
uh it was uh Disney and uh that was
actually through a e that Disney got
involved I think it was like uh a e was
Hearst and is there some kind of a
Canadian Grant or something like way
back that's super super way back super
early days when it's called voice of
Montreal they came to the US they got a
little bit of money I can't remember
where it came from but uh they had big
investment from Rupert Murdoch that was
for that was first and that's that's I
miss Fox Corporation right that was I
think 70 million dollars they had I
believe they'd investment from wpp which
is basic like people really need to look
at what wpp is and start researching
that stuff there's like one company that
owns a piece of all of these different
media properties and then later on they
brought in I think it was a e uh uh
which uh which basically brought that
money from from Disney and and I I think
it's been a long time but I'll just keep
it simple I'll keep it simple
everybody knows Vice
and there was a point where I'm sure
most people watching they're in college
or they're getting out of college and
they're watching those Vice
documentaries and they were awesome they
were super cool yeah and then all of a
sudden somehow what happened I can give
you an example
when I started working for a vice one of
the one of the as part of my negotiation
was I flat out said to to the executives
I do live streaming and Social Media
stuff
what I don't do is documentary stuff I
need that because in between big
breaking news what content is Tim Poole
releasing like what am I covering what
stories am I doing it's not always big
breaking stories so here's what we'll do
I will cover the big breaking news live
stream it to the millions of views and
then in the meantime we will produce
many documentaries around these stories
so put this we'll put it this way if I
go out and I cover say like Desi Park in
Turkey we can do two things we can film
a mini dock about it and we can live
stream it two birds with one stone and
then you guys are helping me where I
need help and they were like that's a
brilliant idea Tim welcome aboard you're
awesome and uh I was the first person
hired for Vice news and then what ends
up happening is one day one of The
Producers comes up to me and he's like
look man I know you really want to do
some of these documentaries and stuff
but uh this was specifically HBO there's
a lot more Nuance to it essentially the
original idea for Vice news was whatever
HBO wouldn't pick up it would run on a
different Channel and he said the thing
is HBO doesn't want white men we gotta
get more uh you know people of color and
women and I was like I'm mixed a mixed
race and they're like yeah that doesn't
matter you look white so and I'm like
and that's the game they play so here I
am I'm hired and then I got pissed and I
went to them and I said here's our
Arrangement here's what you promised and
they're like we know we know we know
they gave me more money and then
eventually I was like I'm out
like if you're gonna tell me that I
can't host things because of my race and
literally they did and I'll also say
this too some other producers like were
very polite to me and basically said
without being mean I wasn't that good at
it and that's totally fine you know I
had one guy be like you got to figure
this stuff out man okay and I'm like
sure and another guy was like the
reality is we can edit this stuff we can
make it however it needs to be made and
we can direct you
hbr doesn't want white people and I was
like okay I was like all right there you
go an experiencing thing at Fusion so
let them let them let them all rot when
I see them failing when I see Vice
infusion wow how funny is this timcast
media is rapidly expanding we got the
coffee company is growing we're hiring
more people we're doing more show deals
we got a big announcement coming soon we
have this Big Show in Miami all of the
success that we've had watching behind
us as all of these people chose to burn
down what they were building because
they would rather bend the knee like
Howard Stern what a spineless pathetic
loser and that's what that's what
happens right when you take big
Investments when you welcome these
people on you give them the power to
destroy you or the power to control you
which and it's it is very it's so funny
because things like uh Tim Castor or
Infowars it's like when you actually
just rely on your audience and you give
your audience what you want what they
want and then they support you for it
you can actually expand and do amazing
things but as soon as the corporations
or the investors come in and start
ordering you around and making decisions
that are not you know focused on what
the audience wants it all starts to fall
apart you know hearing that story and
then in Con in the context of Howard
Stern his time's up he's he's on a list
he's the low-lying fruit right now so we
should Circle back on this and whether
it's six months or a year I have a
feeling Howard Stern is going to be on
the chopping block this is why he's
going so extreme in the other direction
yeah exactly he's so you got a treadmill
right and it's speeding up and people
are being flung off the right side of it
and Howard Stern is running as fast as
he can because he's on that edge and
he's got to just try an inch as much
again it's going to be really difficult
for him
but I mean I got I gotta be honest he
would be better off if he just stayed
himself yeah if he totally just went the
shut up you losers and just stayed
himself he'd be doing way better he
doesn't have to support Trump he doesn't
have to hate vaccines he just needs to
stop being a whiny little loser who's
like just bending the knee and doing
whatever he's told but whatever man hey
he can do he can do whatever he wants uh
he has I wonder if he has any respect
from anyone I'll I'll I'll I'll I'll add
this
he's saying whatever Boomers he thinks
whatever he thinks Boomers want to hear
that's it
that's where he's at
he doesn't care what we think I'm half
his age how old is a guy 70 or something
he didn't care pretty old yeah yeah so
he's he's not trying to impress me he's
trying to impress other Boomers and
that's that that's the reality of how
Generations work like we don't do this
show specifically targeting 19 year olds
we don't do like that like some
companies do that weird stuff where they
try and Pander you know like hello
fellow kids you know like we we just be
ourselves that's what we do we be
ourselves and then what happens is the
attitudes the world view the things we
like resonate with people close to our
age that's exactly what he's doing he is
69 years old yeah look at that he's
ready to run for Congress all right all
right everybody I hate to do this to you
but we're we're gonna do it uh I want to
start this segment by apologizing to all
of you for putting this image in your
head
but it is breaking news and I believe
this shows the depravity and the evil of
the people who are in opposition or I
should say our establishment unit party
and what
from CNN
former Trump aide Cassidy Hutchinson
claims Rudy Giuliani groped her on day
of attack on Capital wow such a shocking
story to come out a day before her book
release is that right yeah it's a day or
two something I don't know the exact
timing but yep wow oh so she accused
Rudy Giuliani of groping her
that's and that that's coming out in her
book so congratulations PR Company hit
the nail on that with the hammer you
people are evil I I have a problem all
right I've always had a problem with
people falsely caught using racism as an
excuse for everything and and my problem
was that racism is a useful term and
it's a real thing and it's something
that honestly I think we should frown
upon like you should not judge people
based on the color of their skin you
shouldn't prejudge people you should
judge people by the way they behave you
know by their actions towards you like
that's that's something that we should
hope that we do in our society
and the way that the left has used
racism as a tactic as opposed to a
description they've used it to say okay
this is this this is why you should hate
this person this is why you should
disregard what this person said and
they've made it so first of all people
have become somewhat numb to the term to
the word racism if you get called to
racist nowadays people are kind of like
are they really saying that I'm racist
are they just calling me a name because
they don't like me so that's a bad thing
because it's useful and second of all it
covers for actual racist it gives them a
way to hide it gives them a way to kind
of you know stealth around and if that's
happening with other things like sexual
assault you don't want so you don't want
people in your Society to say I don't
believe her like that is that's always
been an argument against false
accusations and the more this is used as
a tactic the more real people that were
really sexually assaulted are going to
have problems convincing people that
they were hurt and this is horrible this
is gonna this is going to hurt real
women real live people that are gonna
actually have to deal with the fact that
they get sexually assaulted and then
more people are going to doubt what they
say and it's going to make it it's only
gonna make it harder this is all bad for
us all bad there's no winners so uh I
said Giuliani political adviser Ted
Goodman in a statement called
Hutchinson's claims a disgusting lie
quote it's fair to ask Cassidy
Hutchinson why she is just now coming
out with these allegations from two and
a half years ago as part of the
marketing campaign for her upcoming book
release this is a disgusting lie against
mayor Rudy Giuliani a man whose
distinguished career in public service
includes taking down the mafia cleaning
up New York City and comforting the
nation following September 11th
I'm not going to read you know whatever
she's claiming
but I think this one right here shows
they jump the shark I'm sorry dude when
this crackpot woman who's full of crap
comes out and accuses Rudy Giuliani and
it's funny that what's happening Rudy
Giuliani Russell Brand and Tim bout all
at the exact same time
shocking no one no one believes you
anymore no one believed you since that
mattress girl when those messages got
published showing that she was begging
the dude to hook up with her and then
later claimed that he abused her like
dude I'm just so sick of it these people
are evil and it's it's if if you can't
effectively like we we need to
effectively and and in very simple terms
just show these stories to regular
people
well first of all two and a half years
ago was the heart of the metoo movement
so it would have been a ripe time first
if this happened she should have come
out and been like look this guy's a
creep here's what happened and this is
exactly what happened think about the
inertia that would have gotten at the
time book wasn't done yet exactly
and what I I didn't realize who this
woman was until I you just pulled up her
picture what was her testimony on
January was she the one that said that
Trump tried to steal the the car and
drive it out like oh is that her I think
right what I mean she testified in front
of the January 6 committee uh did she I
just all she's a former Special
Assistant to president Donald Trump and
his Chief of Staff Mark Meadows yeah
yeah he intended to go to the Capitol at
the last minute I think she was the one
who said that he reached for the
steering wheel yeah there you go he
tried he tried to fight and it's it's
like the crazy thing is all it's all
provably false right you can't jump
between the the separate he was in the
was they say he was in the Beast or
whatever he was in he was in the limo I
believe it was right he lunged to the
front of his presidential limo and tried
to turn the wheel there's a there's a
partition has any people ever been in a
limousine before it makes no sense so
yeah she had like reach a crazy January
6th that was a wild day for her I guess
I tried to do that at prom unfortunately
the partition was up yeah I mean look I
whatever this is this is actually a big
Scandal once you reported this because a
lot of people pointed out like hey that
uh in fact what was it like he wasn't in
the limo or something like that or what
was the story it's been a while yeah I
don't I don't even remember I just
started seeing her face that's that's
what it brought to mind and I just
remember it being uh utterly ridiculous
uh like I know again I haven't looked
into her accusations of Rudy Giuliani
but uh on first blush they seem pretty
ridiculous as well and yeah I mean the
question is like okay what like we're
really in a tough spot because it's not
like you can easily like punish people
for making false accusations without
like really damaging the ability for
people to make actual accusations
because Suddenly It's like oh if I make
this accusation and I can't prove it I'm
gonna go to jail I'm just not gonna make
the accusation again so they really they
they sort of have us in a position where
like they can make these accusations
even if they're totally false there's no
risk to them because if we were to try
to put anything in place to prevent
false accusations then really the person
that you're hurting is people making
actual accusations so it's really just
taking advantage of uh of you know good
human nature in a way that only these
evil evil people are capable of doing I
just think it's hilarious that we've got
Russell Brand Tim Ballard and Giuliani
all at the same time like oh dude I'm
sorry man you guys need to coordinate
your campaigns better because it makes
it even less believable you couldn't
spend five minutes to get on the phone
before launching these ridiculous smears
against these dudes
yeah and and again it just has nothing
to do with what the accusations are
about it's it's
just like they're they're investigating
Elon Musk for 900 different things
really they hate him because he wants to
open up uh Twitter X and have free
speech like that's the thing that they
actually want to stop him from doing
they can't just do that so they have to
try to come up with a hundred different
other ways of going at him and uh it's
it's blatant and obvious but uh
frustrating because you have to deal
with all these different attacks all of
a sudden
so it sounds like
the story is that he was talking to
everybody behind like backstage and then
he like put his arm somewhat around her
while holding the documents and kept
talking about the election
and that's that's that's the story and
she goes on to say like you know his
fingers are trailing and I'm just it's
just it's not like cold fingers dude I'm
not it's not real like this is this is
like weird weird psychotic I think the
issue is
I gotta be honest
um women love True Crime you know and
we've talked about this before the
Donald Trump Saga is the premier true
crime podcast
that's why they have Mueller she wrote
or whatever is that show still is they
still doing that podcast unfortunately
yeah how Mueller ended years ago when
did Mueller in 2019
yeah
four years ago and they're still they're
still doing that let's uh let me look
that up and gold nothing burger and and
that by the way that podcast too
if we're talking about the same one the
person who runs it came out everything
came out as being false and completely
made up like her history everything that
she claims to be Etc
Mueller she wrote jeez
how did it just it really it really guys
it's demoralizing that there are people
who vote for for these people I can
understand if you're like I won't vote
for Mitch McConnell I'm like I agree I
can understand if you're like the rank
and file Republicans are our awful
uniparties you know speed bumps for
Democrats and I'm like yeah you know and
then if you go and say like you're gonna
vote for a Democrat I'm just like how
does how do you how does that happen you
know what I mean uh you know most people
are not uh paying attention to this
Source I think you and I were talking
about this uh before the show you know
they just see the headlines and the
mainstream media's primary role in
America today is to tell the truth they
have to tell the truth they have to
stick to the facts but they leave you
believing a lie so and I mean it's with
big things too I mean recently the thing
that was revealed was there was a big
missile attack that they blamed on
Russia that killed civilians and of
course that's the headline that gets him
playing in people's heads Russia evil
Russia evil and then it came out it was
the Ukrainian uh missile but it comes
out quietly several months later nobody
really cares and when you do that enough
and you have enough stories coming out
like that you know they're building
layer upon layer upon layer of lie so
you know I've had conversations with
people talking about January 6th where
they go you know yeah Trump you know
called for violence because this is what
he does remember it during the campaign
you know he his people were violent
during the 2016 campaign it's like okay
so in order to debunk the LIE of 2021 I
gotta go all the way back to 2016 and
all of the lies in between there and
they're not going to believe any of it
either because they're already invested
in the narrative that Donald Trump is
bad yeah the the seed is sprouted so I
posted this on my Twitter today and you
gotta look this story up there's this
guy and he's digging a hole in the beach
right and he goes look at what happened
with the hole that was dug in the beach
and it's just him on Tick Tock and then
it cuts to a story in the news and
they're like it looks like a meteor hit
the beach and we have a scientist here
and they're talking about this guy's
hole that's fake oh that was oh my God I
got it I bought the whole thing yeah so
this is something we talked I talked
with Alex Stein about I was like bro
this is your new play find news stories
and then film yourself doing the thing
in the story and then just edit it
before the news story because people
believe it well and the reason I
believed that it was actually true was
because I believed that they would do
something like that they would reverse
but that's the thing like everybody
wanted to believe that story and if you
actually look at the videos they're not
even the same beach one has houses in
the back left of the video and and the
ocean to the right the video video from
the news report has an island to the
right and and shrubberries to the left
and I'm just like that like the first
time I saw that video I was just like
these are not the same place but then
everybody just keeps retweeting it
because they want it to be real well
same point same exact point maybe maybe
there is like a camera angle thing where
you couldn't see the island and it was
it's true fine whatever but I tell you
you see a news story where they're like
we found a hole in the beach then you go
to the beach dig a hole put your video
in front say haha it was us and people
believe it yeah that actually is pretty
smart either way it got me yeah this is
another thing I was talking about with
um we used to do like viral marketing
pitches one of them was
uh was basically this one of the ideas
is
you can walk around New York City until
you see an ambulance or just like the
moment you see an ambulance doing
something anywhere you film it and then
you come back the next day just before
the same time so the sunlight is is the
same and then film whatever ridiculous
thing you want to be the story so then
the ambulance makes it look believable
and real because if you had uh my joke
was like you have a a Cookie Monster
beating the crap out of a guy dressed
like a giant cookie because it's an
absurd thing and then people are going
to be like that's fake that's not real
and then also it shows the ambulance
there and you're going dude wow and I'm
like whoa now they believe it's real so
that's the viral marketing campaign
strategy you see with videos like this
well when people are doing that quite a
bit the latest one was the woman tearing
down the rainbow flag in the uh
classroom and it just is I mean to me
it's obviously fake from the outset it's
like you've got like 30 year old people
pretending to be high school kids or you
know and I think maybe it's the same
company or a different one that does uh
the you know viral encounters on a plane
and it's like that is not but the full
video shows a scenario and then the
people say thanks for watching our video
right what do you think about this
scenario that we proposed today leave a
comment below and it's like
their their Clips are are obviously fake
when they present them but then other
people take them snip them out of
context and then try and pass them off
and people buy and people believe it hey
you gotta it it really frustrates me
there's the first one I saw was it's the
girl in the classroom wearing a bikini
and the teacher's like you can't wear
that in my class and I'm like these are
adults I just ignore it it's it look if
people are wondering why it is that I
rarely post uh videos that are wrong I
just for whatever reason ignore very
obviously fake posts or I'll call them
out when the Covington kids things
happen my my first thought was I get all
these people hitting me up being like
you got to look at what these kids did
and I'm like what are they doing like
here's the video and I look at it I'm
like I don't understand and they're like
look what the kid's doing I'm like
what's he doing look he got in the face
of that Native American guy and I was
like it's just a video of two people
standing next to each other bro what
you're talking about so when I watch the
full video other way around but people
want things to be true yeah so they just
believe it so when these videos come out
where you've got these actors staging a
high school room and there's a carpet
that's the first thing I notice I'm like
there's no carpet in high school
classroom these people believe in this
stuff and then it turns out they're just
comedians they're actors putting on fake
bits
it's like everybody wants to believe
that a mother tore down a pride flag in
the classroom and I'm like they're in an
office building look at the drop ceiling
yeah it makes no sense there's a drop
ceiling and a carpet that's not a high
school
people want to believe it but the desire
to believe is also emblematic of a lot
of these stories and what we were just
talking about is that when one story
comes out and it's thought of as the
truth for even five minutes or just one
news cycle that's it it's a there's
never kind of like a retroactive
re-examination of the story and that's
ultimately you know everything related
to Trump I I think people really do not
understand what AI is going to do in
2024. yep I think your entirely correct
let me let me give you a scenario
do you remember uh
let's say uh do you remember everything
we talked about earlier when we're
talking about restaurants Chef gruel uh
about 95 of it yeah and so if I played a
recording back for you that sounded
about right you'd be like yeah that
sounds like I can't remember exactly
what we said but that sounds like what
you said yeah and then what if I change
one word
you'd be like so I'll give you a
scenario Donald Trump gets on the phone
in 2024 and he says it's let's let's say
it's September
and he says
to you know Giuliani or whoever look we
gotta get out the vote we got to get
people to go knock on doors we need 50
000 votes it's the only way we're going
to win this one we lost it last time
he doesn't remember exactly what he said
audio gets dropped where Trump goes we
need to fake the vote we need 50 000
votes because we lost by that last time
get it done and they're like whoa and
change one thing get out to fake
what happens then is you'll end up with
Trump in court
I'm using this as a hypothetical
scenario just it could be anybody and
they'll say did you speak with Giuliani
your legal advisor
on or around September 5th in the
afternoon uh I don't recall I might have
okay well I have the call logs here this
is this this is your your your this is
your call logs yes okay I believe so
okay yeah the phone company confirms I'm
gonna play for you some recordings that
we've gotten that were given to us and
then the recording will say Donald Trump
being like hey Rudy it's really good to
hear from you we got big big plans we're
working on great stuff and then anything
because this year he's like sounds like
me yes and do you remember having this
conversation yes I do remember this
conversation show clip one sounds like
you do remember it yes show clip two
sounds like you do remember it yes sound
play clip three sounds like you yes you
were talking about elections and the
work you're doing yes of course and then
play fake clip this is where in the
conversation that you've already agreed
did happen that you were part of and
these things were all true in this clip
you tell Giuliani to fabricate votes no
that's not true that's not real but
you've already confirmed everything else
AI can do this right now and what people
don't understand is you don't remember
everything you said on every
conversation and you don't even know
when you're being recorded they're
they're look
there there will be instances where
somebody is like Trump's been recorded
and they've released these audio tapes
and Trump's response is going to be in
defense of what he said not realizing he
never said it
it's a good point it's a good point and
it's a scary Prospect so what's what's
what's the defense mechanism I mean
there's not ahead of that or is it
there's no defense yeah if audio comes
out that sounds somewhat reasonable like
something Trump may have said Trump's
response is not going to be that's a
deep fake audio never said that because
that's not believable
he'll say well you know I said that
because we are work we like we didn't
mean to to fake it we were uh because
the Natural Instinct people have when
they hear a recording of themselves is
to try and explain away or Justify why
they said the things they said
yeah it is weird we've um we actually
did a thing where it was a guy at
Infowars took my voice and has me
reading like the Declaration of
Independence and it's freaky hearing
your own voice say things that you've
never said it's like a it's not a very
uh comfortable position to be in I
wonder how big of a problem that's going
to be though because I mean we've had
Photoshop forever and and you know ai's
made it extremely easy to make anybody
say anything uh but that's not
necessarily a new technology I wonder
how effective that's going to be or if
that's the ubiquity the fact that anyone
can create an audio recording of any
politician that sounds indistinguishable
for the real from the real thing there's
going to be uh we've already seen it
happen with James O'Keefe they say this
a video went viral claiming to be James
O'Keefe alleging something like we've
uncovered this evidence and it was a
totally fabricated video it was
imperfect because these AIS are not that
good yet but some of them are good
enough and if if you put enough work
into it you can nail the speech so for
instance 11 Labs is the website where
you can take 30 seconds of anyone
talking
upload it and that's it now you can
write anything you want and you'll get
anyone anyone to say it just insert
personality and they'll say what you
want them to say however the inflection
can be off timing can be off you have to
use clever tricks like using ellipses
commas record one sentence erase it
record another sentence sometimes the
sentences aren't ended definitively they
end with an upward inflection and then
you're like okay that's that's weird
but if someone actually spent a week
using this program and generating The
Voice you would not be able to tell the
difference I think the scarier Prospect
though is that even if it is proven
false as long as it's really good and
it's made its way across the entire
social media landscape it's imprinted in
at least 60 percent of Americans Minds
right and then nobody ever covers the
story when it comes out as false that's
the scary thing right so it's really
just adding authenticity to existing
lies
here let's try this I just typed it out
let's see what happens
give it a second this is robot Jordan
Peterson all hail the lobster King
so talk in my language and I want to
stress too this is we don't have this
pull-up Carter so uh I wanna I wanna
stress too that uh this recording I have
of Jordan Peterson's voice I did not do
anything like I did not work on this at
all I literally found like a podcast and
just snipped at 30 seconds and put it in
if you actually found clean clear audio
from Jordan himself and then uploaded it
it would sound way better
so what's the solution just record
yourself at all times just constantly
have that makes it worse that makes it
worse no I mean like you record yourself
yeah go back and go here's what I
actually said it makes it worse because
you're not going to be able to dig
through 5 000 hours of of audio
recordings to figure out what you
actually said and when it was said
someone so I mean how many how many uh
uh what do I do we got an hour and a
half Tim uh Tim pool Daily Show followed
by three hours of Tim cast IRL
four hours four and a half hours every
day of me and various people talking if
someone pulled up a transcript I'd be
like I don't know what you're talking
about yeah every day for three years no
we try to collect footage when we're in
the studio we're just in uh doing drums
a couple months back and we you know
just started recording when we were
there and left it running until it
filled up basically and
you do run into a problem where you've
got so much material you don't know
where to look for stuff unless you
actually start tagging stuff and saying
okay Mark this Mark this Mark this that
was funny or something it just becomes
overwhelming so there's no way you're
going to be able to just like record the
things that you say and say yes I did
say this no I didn't say that there's
it's just there's it's just too much
material too much content yeah in
skateboarding when you're filming a
trick after the trick has landed you
what they used to do because it was mini
DV tapes is they would put their hand
over and they would wave their hand then
when you speed through the video to try
and find out where the trick is you as
soon as you see the hand wave in front
of the camera you need to stop
it still kind of is that way because
you're gonna have 70 video files in your
camera and you're gonna be like which
one was the was the was the Lander and
so you could either tag it in the camera
or you can wave your hand and then you
look and what you see all these clips
and then one with a thumbnail of a hand
in front of it but there's no way you're
going back through 300 Clips throughout
the day seven hours of recorded content
for the past couple days to try and
figure out where someone landed a trick
it's just never gonna happen
if I'm a hostile country I'm gonna use
this to my advantage
right oh I mean people don't even think
about the the war elements that's what
I'm saying we're talking just like
political foes but now you know I'm
North Korea China any of these countries
that we think are ultimately coming
after us and they are I'm I'm gonna just
completely manipulate everybody I I feel
like uh the whole Russia probe and and
stuff that the Clinton campaign did uh
to attack Donald Trump was already like
a laying the groundworker or yeah
demonstrating I'm not I'm I'm not so
sure how much a foreign government is
going to have a preference from one
president to another I mean I I assume
just to create chaos right yeah that
does that I mean that makes sense uh but
I do think that it's it's more of a
honey trap for or honey pot for a
candidate to do something as to an
opposing candidate then then for a a
foreign country
and I and now I mean Americans have
probably never trusted the elections
less you know after the last election
with the uh you know mail-in ballots and
and stuff like that I I think that a lot
of Americans are like you know I don't
have a whole lot of faith in the country
or faith in the election system at all
let's let's jump to the story about the
um the dystopian nightmare that we're
about to embrace and it's probably mean
to say I shouldn't say that Nora link
first in human clinical trials is open
for Recruitment and I want to soften
this a little bit
what's going to happen right now is that
people who are paralyzed who are deaf
who can't see are going to get a chance
to have their lives back or you know if
some people I don't want to imply that
some people are are you know miserable
or unhappy some people are totally fine
and happy and they've adapted and
they're living good lives but some
people may be thinking this is my chance
to maybe walk again this is why
neuralink is awesome the scary thing is
Nora link is the is the door
that once you open it up The Path out
leads to people isolating themselves in
pods where they have feeding tubes full
of pumping bug slime into their bellies
while they live in the matrix by choice
but this is the the latest big news Elon
Musk tweeted about it saying
the first human patient will soon
receive a neuralink device this
ultimately has the potential to restore
full body movement in the long term
norling hopes to play a role in AI risk
civilization risk reduction by improving
human to Ai and human to human bandwidth
by several orders of magnitude imagine
if Stephen Hawking had had this
um I also want to just point out what
he's saying about AI risk civilization
risk reduction
he's saying that if humans integrate
with the AI it won't destroy us
he's talking about integrating human
brains with other human brains
you know I think Elon does great work
and I think it's important that you know
to a certain degree like we certainly
want to cure people who are paralyzed
with medical technology
but I gotta say man
it's gonna get scary you guys ready to
plug your brain into the Matrix yeah
absolutely not no that's it's like yeah
I like I like what Elon Musk is doing
with Twitter I'm not about to let him
put a computer in my head I mean that
that's ridiculous and you know the other
aspect of this is that the first people
to take advantage of this will be like
the elite the people in the um you know
and take advantage of it in a way that
is more than just like helping a
paralyzed person walk which you know
obviously that's the way that they're
going to introduce it because who who
would disagree with that but you know it
was way beyond that when neuralink is
capable of in terms of like increasing
your IQ or your uh all sorts of stuff
and so you know you're going to have a
sort of feedback loop where the people
in the highest positions of power in the
society get it first and that just
solidifies their position as they uh you
know continue to uh
they say those who have quadriplegia due
to cervical spine spinal cord injury or
ALS may qualify so for now I mean we're
not talking about plugging people's
brains into the Matrix neural link is
actually going to be saving lives and
and curing ailments and I can respect
that I know a lot of people are saying
don't rag on neurolink because it's
going to provide uh you know treatment
for a lot of people and that's really
really cool so uh my fear is just that
if we go to the point ever get to the
point where we can read right into a
person's brain experiences
yeah No One's Gonna live in the real
world anymore well the other aspect is
you know the the gray reset the the
world economic form right you'll own
nothing you'll have no privacy but
you'll be happy I mean that that dates
back to the you know 1960s when you had
Aldous Huxley saying basically they'll
put you in a position where you ought
not be happy but you'll be made happy
when they literally are releasing
dopamine so you're sitting there on like
a and you know this is like the 1960s
version but you're sitting there on an
assembly line you should be like
miserable like God this is awful but
instead you're like this is the best
thing I've ever this is the most fun
I've ever had is putting together these
car parts because they're literally
activating the pleasure Center of your
brain as you're doing this do you guys
uh you guys know what uh you know you
know the story of the monkey's paw right
yes the monkey spot it gives you three
wishes but it twists your wishes into
awful ways and or or there's just like
Needful Things this Trope of be careful
what you wish for has been around for a
long time I remember uh when I was
little I can't remember what what movie
we were watching I was watching with my
family and it's like somebody gets a
monkey's paw or whatever and then
they're like I wish for a million
dollars and then all of a sudden like
the person's wife walks out to pick up a
newspaper and gets hit by a car killing
her instantly and then you know the guy
in the car is like oh no I'll give you a
million dollars settlement or whatever
like he or an insurance pay out they're
like you're being awarded a million
dollars so that the wish is twisted my
dad was always like you know you know
how you beat the monkey Spa you wish for
happiness wish that you were happy
and what could it do to twist it and I
was like
it'll put you in a mental institution in
a straight jacket Bang Your Head on the
wall and goes but you're happy
and I'm like that's an interesting way
of viewing happiness is that it's
technically the truth yeah there's a uh
that's the happiness they'll give you
there's a Chuck palahnik uh short story
that's kind of like that where it's this
phenomenon where uh all these kids in
high school realize that if you like
electrocute yourself you basically like
lobotomize yourself and so it's like a
trend of kids like electrocuting
themselves and lobotomizing themselves
because they'd rather be happy and
mentally incapacitated than have to deal
with the stresses of uh of real life yo
people are going to be like in the real
world I work at uh uh you know I work a
menial job but when I go home to my pod
and plug in man I host this big nightly
podcast with millions of followers it's
really great you know to a Morning Show
yeah and I mean that and that again you
know this is what the the people that
are whether we like it or not planning
our future right the global government
that already exists and is in operation
right now they you know come out and say
they're like you know once we have all
these robotics people are going to be
useless so we have to find something for
them to do we have to find something to
occupy their time which is exactly that
it's put you in a pod connect you to the
neuro link and suddenly you're happy and
and playing video games but you guys you
guys wouldn't want to play video games
in the norlink no I mean do you play
video games yeah what's your favorite
game Baldur's Gate you're playing
Baldur's Gate right now I'm not playing
the third one you're not playing third
no wait what are you talking about how
you playing Ballers game you're not
playing the new one and I just played
the one from 1995. well it's a really
great game you wouldn't want to actually
be able to experience being in the world
of Baldur's Gate and throwing Fireballs
at dragons and uh um
not if that means I'm putting a USB port
in the back of my head I think it'll be
Wireless
well either way no I think but I mean
that is the danger I mean we're already
even with the level of Technology we
have now we're already experiencing this
where like so many even like my friends
like they get their fulfillment in the
facsimile of Success Through video games
have you ever heard the phrase fully
automated luxury communism that is the
future that a lot of people want and
that is the future that a plugged in
neuralink pod offers you don't have to
do anything if you're laying in the pot
it's fully automated your serotonin and
dopamine centers are stimulated for you
so you are you own nothing and you're
happy and you literally just exist in
the pot here's a go on a Samuel Rucker
with a super chat saying don't forget
that neurolink can be used as an
interface for a super soldier super suit
like Iron Man that was literally the
second to musk tweeted about uh what's
called then this the next tweet that he
had it was a little clip from Star Wars
with Luke Skywalker's hands but but the
you know you wonder how it is that Tony
Stark Pilots the Iron Man suit well it's
going to be human it's gonna be what
computer brain interface but I I do
think the moment everybody says no
everybody says they won't do it
everybody said they won't get a cell
phones everybody's got a cell phone and
everyone's like I don't want a
government tracking device in my pocket
now I have three only old people will
say no only people our age and older oh
I think a lot of people want this like I
mean we look at it through a critical
lens but I think that actually there's a
significant portion of Americans who
will Who want to be crazy and they want
to immediately Reach This Nirvana that
is being sold to it
people will sell
experiences yeah so like you're you're a
chef so what you do is what you have to
do is plug in the norlink cook the fancy
meal
film it and then eat it and it records
what your brain is saying as you're
eating this food and then that
experience of eating this delicious meal
can be then sent to the game world where
it now appears on the menu like someone
has to record the brain patterns to give
to another person before it can you
can't just go into this video game this
neuraling world and be like I want a
filet mignon someone's got to record
what a brain experiences what signals
are sent when someone is eating a
delicious medium rare filet mignon so
basically this is a way to become vegan
without being vegan right oh I mean dude
you're gonna eat the bugs come on yeah
you're gonna you're gonna go in your pod
and you're gonna plug the feeding tube
into your neck yeah exactly and then
you're going to Zonk out and then you're
going to live for like I don't there's
the idea that they could do
um make make you exp like time dilation
in the neural link like speed things up
so that in the real world it's you know
eight hours of sleep but you live for 80
years or something like that I don't
know about that that may or may not be
true but you're gonna plug in you're
gonna get home from work or we're gonna
be like finally and go back to being
president again plug in your feeding
tube and then wake up as the president
oh my God basically you know what's
funny this is a rudimentary like like
San Francisco this is San Francisco
right where everybody's being given
drugs and they're laying on the streets
and they don't have jobs but now we're
actually going to turn it into something
a lot more digital and and effective
it's a scary thing I think the the big
hurdle for neuralink in terms of
commercial ubiquity will be it has to be
Wireless
they're like there's already the problem
of human rejection
so there are people who will cut open
their fingers and put neodymium magnets
in their fingers and then sew it shut
and this gives you uh I think it's some
people I think it's called Electro
perception or perhaps Electro sense and
the magnet inside your finger reacts to
electromagnetic fields giving you the
ability to feel EMF waves that's crazy
it gives you an additional sense I think
it's funny that people say we have five
senses we actually have substantially
more than five senses but you know
whatever you it's like you know what do
they say touch smell see and hear
whatever and and taste but you also have
balance you also have temperature
there's a bunch of other ones and uh but
anyway
if you want to feel electromagnetic
fields you they they're the people who
do this so you know I don't recommend it
but the body rejects it they take a
magnet they code it in some polymer
stick it in your finger sew it shut but
slowly over time your body pushes it out
and then eventually it breaks and just
rips out of your finger
if we're gonna do a neural link how do
you stop the body from rejecting it I
think what they're doing right now with
neurolink and the stuff that I've seen
is they're very very thin copper wires
that just rest on the nerve connections
something like that
the big challenge for neuralink going
commercial and ubiquitous is going to be
no one's going to want to get surgery
I mean maybe if it's like a tattoo if
they're like look we take this thing and
we go boom boom boom boom boom and we
put these these uh you know copper wires
in this and super easy anyone can do it
it takes 15 minutes maybe people would
do it as long as they're drilling
quarter-sized holes into your skull
people are going to have a little bit of
ick factor and they're going to be a
little apprehensive about that but but
people are already getting the chips in
their hands I mean you know the the skin
is not like a decade yeah yeah it's been
a while there will be people that are
going to go ahead and say we'll do it
I'll do it right now there will be
people that'll that'll definitely do
that there's without a question
biohacking and stuff standing in line
for the orb thing right uh yeah people
people are going to be into this so
absolutely so I I mean I guess it's just
it is like literally just like a
spiritual uh thing where you have to
like reject the the falsehood even if
it's Pleasant even if it feels good even
if uh it seems like a a easier
experience than real life you have to
recognize that it's not real uh and and
rejected on that uh ground alone let's I
want to jump to the next story ladies
and gentlemen and now for the coup de
gras
from
ncherald.co.nz Donald Trump suggests
feeding migrants to alligators to fix
overrun border security
uh spoiler no we didn't but I absolutely
love the headline I am curious how many
migrants it would take to be fed to
alligators before they would stop Trump
posted a meme
disavow he wrote problem solved and it
says new border security and it's a
bunch of alligators those are alligators
what's the difference like crocodiles
have like skinnier faces right I I don't
I'm not a an animal zoologist they both
look really hungry we'll work for food
Trump did not did not suggest feeding
migrants to alligators because their
headline implies Donald Trump said what
if we capture a migrant and then throw
them into an alligator Den what Trump
was saying is a meme based on an old
story this is from uh New York Times
2019 shoot my immigrants legs and build
alligator moat behind Trump's ideas for
the Border
it was a widely reported story that
Donald Trump wanted to put a bunch of
alligators in the Rio Grande
is this is not real life these are
hoaxes the media is full of crap and
once again they're full of crap Trump
posted a joke but I just I absolutely
love the headline like the reality of
these people live in I mean no wonder
Howard Stern hates Trump I mean if if I
legitimately thought Trump was going to
kidnap migrants and throw him into
alligator pits I'd be really concerned
as well well this goes back to the the
consuming the headlines digesting these
crazy headlines and then people actually
believe it this will probably be brought
up in one of the debates as an actual
question yeah Donald Trump I could say
that he threw them into the alligator's
mouth exactly so now we have this one
this look at this tweet from uh bill
milugan
it's a total free-for-all in Eagle Pass
right now Mass illegal Crossing taking
place for over an hour and a half almost
two years to the day we saw 15 000
Haitians under the bridge in Del Rio we
now have thousands of predominantly
Venezuelans Gathering under Eagle Pass
Bridge
yeah I'm sorry dudes like
the Republicans don't have your back
Democrats don't have your back they're
selling you out they're gutting the
system and they're doing with a smile on
their face so if this is the situation
we have and to be completely honest I
would say Trump joking about it is
inappropriate
inappropriate why well the joke's funny
but we need real action this is a
desperate situation there's an emergency
declaration in Eagle Pass
take a look from the Daily Mail
Eagle Pass Texas declares state of
emergency as shocking photos showed
being overwhelmed by migrants with 4 000
streaming across the border today 4 000
today you know why the mayor wants money
why he declared a state of emergency he
wants money from the federal government
to help these people and bring more in
yeah they're not stopping it they're not
they're not issuing a state of emergency
to be like help help it must stop
they're saying no say to emergency we
need more money give us more so we can
send them to to your home in New York
yeah and this is I mean that's what uh
Alejandra Mallorca is like you know
testifies to where they're like you know
you're doing nothing to stop this
Invasion he's like actually we made an
app that makes it very easy for people
to come in Legally and it's like that's
the opposite of what we want you to do
dude like that's literally the opposite
and I mean it's the same thing that's
happening in uh the Italian
um Island where there's now yeah where
there's now 18 000 migrants to to a uh
six thousand five six thousand yeah I
mean so I mean this is a coordinated
plan right this is a coordinated
well-funded these ngos and supernational
organizations like the UN are paying for
people to travel instructing them how to
get around the American law every single
one of these organizations should be
rooted out and arrested and charged with
uh you know conspiring to circumvent
American laws it's and none of the you
know none of these people are actual
Asylum Seekers none of them are refugees
migrants yeah so I mean there's some
Chinese that that are coming over the
southern border that are coming as as
actually refugees they're trying to
escape China but yeah but like but but
generally speaking generally speaking 90
plus percent are not refugees they are
economic migrants we especially with
lampedusa the U.N issued this report in
like 2017 or whatever these are economic
migrants seeking jobs in Europe that's
it and the media lies and calls them
refugees over and over and over again
because they're evil
and they don't look at what's happening
when look you take a group of people who
have one set of morals and another
people with a different set of morals
and they fight
we want to avoid that we want people to
live together and so you look what's
happening in Europe and you have these
these these stabbings these murders
these horrible crimes it's like well
you're not properly assisting the
integration of people into your country
you're opening your border and letting
them run straight through what happens
violent crime and then that breeds more
racism people people take issue and they
they assume race is the problem when the
reality is two different cultures that
don't mesh and how about the reality of
nature people who don't have stuff are
going to take it when they want it so in
lampeduso you've got these videos of
people setting up barricades what are
they supposed to do these people come to
the island and now they're like now we
need food now we need shelter now we
need stuff and if they they can't they
can't manual they can't fabricate it
from thin air they're gonna take it from
someone yeah and let's even zoom out
from the kind of the political debate
regarding this issue and let's just look
at the logistics logistically this isn't
impossible to handle for a country large
or small so just pull back out of this
and just recognize we cannot do this
because we're not set up we don't have
the infrastructure necessary strictly
even from that perspective the fact that
that New York has basically buckled
under the the busing of a just a portion
of the migrants that are coming to Texas
and the city that has the financial
services sector based in it they have
the city itself has city taxes then
there's state taxes as well and they
can't produce uh uh you know they can't
take care of migrants they can't they
can't take you know to welcome the
migrants that just the ones they're
getting it should indicate to the rest
of America that these are massive
problems that a handful of states are
dealing with you know people in New
Hampshire aren't making a stink about
the people that are coming into the
country because it doesn't affect them
right and New York they were very happy
to be as NIMBY as it gets you know they
were they were like you know you
horrible people you horrible racists
down there on the on the border Texas
you're full of races how dare you turn
these people how dare you not take care
of them and then they get a portion of
them and the infrastructure is buckling
they're falling apart and now they're
calling uh their their mayor Donald
Trump yeah yeah and it's calling him
Trump yeah so someone was a pizza
you know but the the point is like the
rest of the country should be able to
see this and say okay I at least can
understand because obviously New York
can't handle it they're they're it's you
know they're they're buckling under the
pressure so if New York City can't
handle it with the infrastructure of the
money and everything they do you can't
expect you know Texas and New Mexico and
Arizona to handle the type of influx
it's not possible and that's that's the
beauty of what bussing them to New York
did is you can't avoid it right because
these problems that are so massive in a
place like Texas where you have
thousands of miles of unoccupied land
you can put them on a base somewhere you
can put them in a tent somewhere and the
the uh you know they don't actually
affect the daily lives although then you
know a place like El Paso they obviously
do Eagle Pass they obviously do and it
is it is purely a matter of choice right
like we're making we're choosing to have
this happen and I think the uh the
Haitian example is a great example how
there was 15 000 people it was a crisis
it went on and on and then there was
like the scandal with the whipping it
got embarrassing the next day they were
gone the next day it got taken care of
so it's not a matter if we can't handle
this we can't do this this is all being
done on purpose this is all a choice
that we're making and I honestly don't
see an end to this to the extent that
why wouldn't the people in charge want
to keep a constant cycle going where
you've got the first world producing
excess amounts of goods shipping it to
the third world keeping their birth
rates High a pathway to where those
people in the third world are moving
into the first world in the first world
the cultural and and spiritual impetus
is to strip them of all of their
cultural identity fold them into this uh
you know Global homogenized soulless
plastic Society where the people that
come in don't have kids either by choice
or because they've been poisoned with
the poison the food and Waters so they
die out within a couple Generations only
to be replaced by another so you've got
this like laundry cycle continuously
going where nobody has any cultural
um uh
is staying power basically so there's
never enough people with enough culture
to overthrow the ruling classes just to
constantly in a constant influx of new
people being brought in uh deracinated
uh destroyed uh politically and and
spiritually only to be replaced by
another crop for people I think it's
simpler than that it's an eternal win
for the Democrats yeah right the
Democrats look good when they say oh we
should we should take care of people
that come here they're all refugees Etc
et cetera give they they always have the
nice sounding yeah the emotional the
emotional pull um and that pays
dividends the people that come in
they're like well the Democrats are the
people that want to have the services
that provide provided me with help when
I got in or helped with my family helped
me get my family in it's an eternal win
for Democrats it's a loser for the
American people right the American
people are the ones that are paying for
this the American people have to have to
make sure that the people that come into
the US have places to live and and they
have to share resources and and you know
jobs and all sorts of things you know
low-skilled workers coming to the U.S
makes it harder to get jobs for for
Americans that are here that's that's
something that's clearly obvious it's a
bad thing for the American people but as
long as there are enclaves of wealthy
people that are looking for uh you know
migrant workers and stuff like that or
that are looking to vote with their
heart and stuff like that you're going
to have Democrats that are going to be
like hey we can't be mean to these
people we can't we can't be we can't
turn them away we have to take care of
them Etc so it's literally an eternal
win for Democrats as it destroys the
country I just don't understand why we
haven't started just sending everyone to
Canada
[Laughter]
Canadian government would not be able to
reject it the way the super woke they
just be like oh you know we welcome
diversity it's like New York's not far
away man it's a couple hours well it's
gonna say it's about the same flight
right from El Paso to New York versus El
Paso up into Canada just get some buses
bus route to Montreal is only a couple
hours beautiful and then uh
I don't know it'll be interesting uh
people don't realize this though there
actually is a border crisis for Canada
migrants are going to Canada via where
they're they're uh in Upstate New York
I'm pretty sure that's where it's at
they're okay they're illegally crossing
the border because it's easier to get
into Canada than it is to get in the
United States obviously Canada's got
there there was a video I saw where uh
some people just like drove across the
border and then tried sneaking in that
way and they got caught but it really is
that easy I mean what do you think like
all this empty Wilderness they're gonna
catch people walking just through the
woods
there's actually a a photo that went
viral read it a while ago where the
border from Canada to the US was it was
a small chain literally just a chain
between two posts that was like a foot
off the ground and a sign hanging from
it saying Canadian U.S border and it was
like someone lived there and they were
like yeah if I if I go my backyard I'll
be in the United States and you just
literally walk in it's like what do you
do
maybe maybe the solution is we just say
Canada we got a bunch of people how
would you like to have a bunch of people
man they got the space yeah there's a
lot of oil up there in the in the in the
Northern Territories or whatever
wherever in Canada amazing Seafood
they're gonna find out that if you go to
Canada and ask for health care that you
might get killed so and people will be
like no I don't want to go
I don't know I thought Canada was very
uh uh Progressive
isn't dying
yeah if you're homeless yeah remember I
give a house I don't um have you
considered the suicide Booth it's funny
that Futurama thought it was a joke I
guess but they did predict in the future
although for them it was the year 3000
and it's already happening in 2023. well
it's to be fair and Futurama they did
say America's favorite suicide Booth
since 2008 so oh is that what I really
said
yeah so they they nailed that one
no it's it's uh it's a pretty sick
what's going on but again you know it's
not a coincidence this is happening in
America and Europe at exactly the same
time with two completely different uh
excuses for why it's happening but also
both excuses uh actually are predicated
on actions that America and or Europe
has taken right we started the wars in
the Middle East that has led to the
immigration crisis a lot of the
countries to the South have been
collapsed as a consequence of
intervention by the CIA so they create
the problem then the solution is
basically to destroy our civilization
over it and also it's the only
civilization in the world that has a
high level living standards that we have
because you know people who are are used
to having a much lower living standard
are happy to have just a slight increase
here in America which would which would
be a major decrease to the average
American so they're they're willing to
sort of put up with uh having less than
Americans and Europeans would have and
they also don't have the cultural and uh
I don't know I don't know to what extent
it's racial but uh you know the the
cultural uh Heritage of freedom and free
speech and all of these uh European
ideals that were developed over
Millennia that are anathema to the
people that want to control everybody
and want you know silent complicity to
their really anti-human demands so yeah
we're gonna go to super chats so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe Thrive to
this channel share the show with your
friends and head over to timcast.com
click join us become a member because
the members only show will be up in
about a half an hour it's not so family
friendly and we even take calls from all
of you as a member you sign up for the
Discord Community you hang out with
like-minded individuals share ideas work
on projects they have an after after
show even that the members put together
so uh join up at timcast.com let's read
Steven says says first that's right
buddy for two dollars you get the shout
out as the first Super Chat
congratulations uh unfortunately uh you
uh to the other people who have who've
chatted you didn't you didn't get it
first sorry uh paps McGee says did I get
the first love y'all sorry sir you did
not
yes man says Tim you mentioned at one
point that you have too many eggs have
you considered appropriating a freeze
dryer and turning them into powder on
another note will you give your opinion
on the toilet meme I don't know what
that is
I don't know that one and uh we the eggs
get eaten I'm just saying like we here
get it we're getting like 30 something
eggs per day that's a lot and then uh we
eventually either build them up and then
just eat them all at once or people just
take them
but I had a bunch the other day yeah we
gotta we gotta make deviled eggs again
that's always the best because it's like
if I'm gonna have breakfast I could have
three eggs and so you know with like
three eggs and bacon or something it's
like kind of a lot right but if you give
me deviled eggs I can have like 15. yep
that's just like a big plate 30 halves
you know and everything I just keep
eating them so good I know the best
thing ever
all right
Clint Torres says howdy people howdy
Amos Moses says I don't like the idea of
a dress code but like three-fourths of
the illegal immigrants dress better than
fetterman after trekking through the
Wilderness I mean but that that's
literally true it is I'm afraid like
they're wearing jeans and t-shirts and
and like you'll see a guy wearing like a
long sleeve shirt looks kind of okay and
wearing jeans and they're walking and
waving and it's like it's infuriating
they just open the bore and let them all
come in without any kind of process but
fetterman looks like he just woke up
uh yeah that's true that's just
incredibly frustrating I don't get what
it is what like what but grand
demoralization scheme they're trying to
pull off here by just lowering standards
across the board constantly I don't know
I don't even get what the argument's
supposed to be for it uh but it's uh
that fetterman guy he's annoying isn't
he shredkowski says Chef gruel I learned
a lot about cooking and seed oil since
you were on last food prep has never
been easier the the vinegar eggs thing
that was the secret yeah that's it acid
in the eggs on anything at the end but I
did get a lot of questions people were
like do I add it in the beginning do I
add it during or do I add it at the end
always at the end so lemon juice acid
how do we cook brussels sprouts what do
you do uh brussels sprouts you got to
blanch them first right so the key with
brussels sprouts is you cut them in half
okay and then you cut the bottoms off
and then you cook them in boiling salted
water for about 45 seconds then shock it
in ice water and then from there you fry
it people fry it went from the raw State
and then the outside overcooks and This
Bitter and the inside is still hard
really yeah so by cooking it in boiling
water you're cooking it from the inside
out so it's an even cook all the way
through and then a light fry really the
restaurant out here they put peanut
butter and jelly on them oh I love it I
love it I love it it's not they don't
actually call peanut butter and jelly
they call it a peanut sauce with a
cranberry reduction but I'm like yeah
other peanut butter jelly brussels
sprouts and they're good we'll have to
do some Brussels sprout chips to go well
so I noticed something like recently
they're different because normally we
get them like they're so good I think
they changed chefs and whatever the chef
is doing he's missing something that's
why I asked yeah I think it's missing
something a lot of times chefs will just
deep fry it and that's like that I mean
yeah fats flavor but still
cheating I'll take it I love brussels
sprouts man we had uh we went to a
Peruvian place me and my girlfriend the
other day and we had um sweet uh sweet
uh Thai Thai chili sauce yes yes sweet
soy sauce yeah oh man insanely good so
good
all right neurodivergent says Tim please
talk about the 1 million March for
children today thousands of videos and
photos from X on x from Ottawa our
capital and other places it's the
biggest thing since the Convoy wow I did
see some stuff about it I saw there were
some protesters too are there Communists
saying that they that children were
theirs I tweeted about that uh that's
great uh I don't remember exactly what
the chant was but essentially they were
saying that you know your children are
ours and that's literally what this the
the left believes they believe that they
should be raising your children because
you might raise them incorrectly you
stinking bigot all right what do we got
Raymond g Stanley Jr says we knew
Veritas was dead the moment the board
foolishly thought they stood a chance
without James it's nice to see morons
get what they deserve so I I don't know
if this is confirmed just yet but there
is a viral tweet going around where
someone said Veritas is ceasing all
operations and uh so far there's just
one individual Twitter account reporting
this
maybe there's more information out we'll
see
what have we here
Horsehead says Tim sorry if you've
already talked about it wanted to hear
your thoughts on Eduardo verastigi
running for president in Mexico and also
Tim Ballard getting the Russell Brand
treatment have them back we need to talk
about uh Tim Ballard uh Eduardo seems
like a good dude I don't know enough
about him all I can say a sound of
freedom is awesome he was here he seems
like a great guy and I don't really have
a strong opinion on the uh Mexican
presidential race because I don't know
enough about it
but from like if if someone's upset like
who would who would you want to have I'd
be like well I know Edward oh he's a
nice guy like I guess that's all I can
do him but uh reality is I don't know
enough about his politics or anything
happening there to to you know
to know but basically one of the guys
behind sign of freedom is running for
president in Mexico I don't know yeah
yeah is that yeah that's what it is
right Bender the offender uh Bender the
offender that's the earlier iteration he
eventually became the gender bender says
I have a theory on why so many illegal
migrants are being let through due to
low military applicants they may be
trying to recruit the fighting age males
that end of the country and guarantee
them citizenship well they are doing
that for sure yeah I mean yeah but
they're not doing it enough no but but
they've said that they're like because
of the low recruitment they're uh
starting to recruit illegal aliens or
not necessarily illegal aliens but
foreigners you know they're basically
saying you can get citizenship through
military service yeah basically they're
saying service guaranteed citizenship
yeah it's we're following the path of
the downfall of Rome is that what Rome
did they brought in the outside forces
to fight for them yeah because and
they're also you know the forces that
aren't going to have any compunction
about violating the Constitution and
attacking American citizens yeah that's
a recipe for disaster yeah oh boy and
they're letting him become police
officers too now so you know this is the
private militia of the elites uh to be
used against the American people
mayor of baseville says my cousin T's
pumpkin spice pancake mix arrive today
my daughter and I had them for dinner
and they were succulent I don't know if
succulent is the right word for pancakes
it's not right if there's a lot of syrup
on there I guess it doesn't look refer
to like more like you know uh like a
biting into a ripe mango yeah fruit yeah
something juicy yeah yeah oh the
pawpaw's everywhere crazy do you guys
you know papa is no Billy banana they
look like uh they look like like baby
blue potatoes or like yeah baby mango
potato yeah it's crazy because if you
find one is that what I'm seeing on the
ground out here the green well there's
also black walnut everywhere the black
wallet are balls yeah yeah and the
pawpaw are ovals but uh you get one
that's ripe you can just peel it right
open and it looks like mango it's nuts
and you just eat it yeah but mango is
better
but you know I'll take Papa it's fine
they're on the same family right yeah
and also you you can bake the pawpaw too
into like Breads and custards and all
that so it's an amazing base flavor yeah
it's really good probably like 50 000 of
them in our backyard no joke they fall
in your head when you walk through the
trees that's amazing so I'm just gonna
say it makes a great name for a
grandfather too but Paul Paul yeah
grandfather bread yeah yeah but I guess
I was reading it the reason you don't
get them in the uh there you can't get
them in stores there's a lot of fruits
people don't get in stores because
they're hard to cultivate and they they
break real easily so they're pollinated
by uh beetles and flies and they're good
right about now into mid-october and
then they're gone and they're just
rotting on the ground so it's like not
something you can easily get but right
now Now's the Time baby now it's Paw Paw
pie Paw Paw bread Paw Paw mash it is
pawpaw season that's like uh loquats or
kumquats in uh in Texas because they
they
um get rotten so easily they're
impossible to like ship or sell so you
just gotta pick them up through there's
also probably like seven million grapes
I'm not even exaggerating they're not
that big they're called Frost grapes
they're super tart you got you're
supposed to freeze them or something but
there's I don't know this freezing
didn't do anything they're still tart
but they're just everywhere oh those are
like the labrusco grapes that's for like
a sweet wine just start making one well
yeah there's videos of people they take
the frost grapes and they make wine with
it yeah because it's all it's it's
literally you walk outside you're gonna
see eight thousand grapes anywhere you
look in a patch there's one tree that's
just covered in grapes I mean imagine
two million grapes and a big bushel
hanging from a tree you you walk up
under the leaves and you're like holy
crap but they're not big they're small
yeah yeah exactly exactly
I don't know where they came from this
they just appeared they weren't here
last year but I'm I'm down for it we got
to do something with them I guess
they're they're they're really big and
they're ready to be eaten right now and
so I think now is about the time and
then first Frost is usually when they
say they're perfect yeah ice one yeah
yeah because it freezes all the water in
the grapes so you're left with the sugar
so then you crush them when they're
frozen and then it extracts all the
sugar it converts some kind of acid in
it when it freezes yeah which causes a
tartness I like tart you know I like
sour candy and everything like that
all right let's grab some more Super
chats
Gary Mark says UAW on strike fighting to
get our wages and benefits back on track
from the 2008 disaster wow it's been
that long huh that's crazy
says Peck that like button you do it
Brandon Anson says Tim if you're
building an anti-time Square can you
please call it space Circle
space Circle ha ha uh I mean Ian's idea
was to call it Public Square which
sounds really cool but that's up to
Public Square because it's like that's a
brand name you know what I mean but that
could be cool
seriously JK says how can the lack of
action at the southern border not be
treasonous the government is actively
assisting a foreign invasion of its own
soil against your wishes too but there
are too many people in this country that
vote for Democrats and you know them
there you go what are you gonna do
secede that was that that was their
argument Democrats proposed that in the
in the Boston Globe story well if Donald
Trump gets elected I mean it's you know
there's all there's certain things that
only the government can take care of
like me as an individual I can't Patrol
our border that's like if you're gonna
boil the purpose of government down to
one single thing it's to protect the
borders if they're not doing that I
don't see why we're paying taxes to him
David Murdock art says drag the Dead is
on sale this week on Steam we just
pushed our final update the social
credit score and Equitable leaderboard
no matter how low you place you'll still
get first we're all mad here let's build
counterculture pick it up really cool
man drag the Dead video game on Steam
right on
grandstanding and hot dogging says hey
Tim love the show cousin T is a grifter
he knew nothing about politics he didn't
even know the ingredients of his
pancakes or what bleached versus
unbleached flour was do not do business
with him you're above that well I don't
know nothing about that what I know of
Terence seems to be an okay guy not sure
why you know people would call mcgrifter
because he didn't know enough about
politics he actually told that story he
wasn't a big political guy but then he
started pushing back and that got him
involved and then when they canceled
that jemimae says I'm gonna I'm gonna do
it myself I dig it but I don't know
whatever and keep in mind his defense
and co-packing when they change
ingredients sometimes it's like
difficult to actually get through the
manufacturer so I'm sure he had a set
recipe and just for the purposes of
co-packing they may have changed some of
the ingredients without him knowing oh
there you go
what do we got
Callum dynick says UK just went full
1984 with the Internet safety act they
just passed as well demands the ability
to read all private messages and control
what can be called true
wow
well V for Vendetta you know that's how
they get there what can be called true
that's uh
that's a heck of a phrase huh yeah right
Shane H Wilder says I want to applaud
Rumble it takes balls of brass to tell a
government to go stick it for the
linemen yeah but brumble also told and
they tell France to go stick it or
something there's another country where
they were just like get out of here yeah
I think France was like Bam Bam RT and
he was like Chris was like no get out of
here dude I think it was France I don't
know I don't want to be smirched the
good name of France unless they actually
did it
Santa laughing says what is
happening to Russell Brand proves that
authoritarians gotta authoritate
yep like let's just let's just say that
one more time the a UK government member
of a member of parliament contacted
social media networks and said they
contented other networks to take away
Russell Brand's income that's crazy
rumble's an American company they're
like hey we're a foreign country stop
stop allowing them to make money
what get out of here dude that's evil
man that's dark stuff that's so evil
it's pretty serious too
all right I'm Memphis says Russell needs
to file charges against the UK
government and all capitulating parties
I'm sure his fans support him I'll have
been myself actions like this are
unacceptable and must be fought I do
think he probably has a claim against
YouTube I don't think YouTube is allowed
to strip like to break their contract
with you uh
there there's something there I mean the
argument they'll make as it says in
there that they can break the contract
at any point for any reason but I I
think some courts reject that
like that because it's like an
unenforceable clause or something like
that but I don't know for sure I'm not a
lawyer
Gary G says Joe Rogan needs to have an
emergency podcast with Russell Brand
ASAP yeah you know he should that'd be
very controversial wouldn't it
waffle Sensei Tim with what you know
about YouTube's rules and policies can
Russell Sue Google for some kind of
breach of contract yeah so this is the
issue with um
it was uh I'm forgetting the guy's name
who was the guy who uh he's uh the
vaccine reporter guy from one of the New
York Times I can't remember his name he
got banned from Twitter because the
government demanded it and then he sued
and won
oh yes and there you go there you go the
issue there was that they cited a
specific reason as to why they banned
them if they said for no reason at all
he's banned then they probably would
have been okay but because I set it a
reason now they had to back up and
justify that reason that's the thing
with YouTube YouTube said offline
behavior is taken into account as well
YouTube will now have to justify what
they're claiming as offline behavior and
if they then assert that Russell Brand's
behavior is true which is basically what
they're saying that's defamation
Russia uh Russell's should sue YouTube
for defamation
um per se
defamation per se is harsher than
defamation a lot of people like you
can't sue for defamation Because the
actual male standard times V Sullivan ah
that doesn't apply to defamation per se
defamation per se doesn't require
damages either it's if so if you accuse
someone of like having an infectious
disease or if having committed a serious
crime that's defamation per se it's so
egregious that the claims themselves
warrant like heightened status or
whatever
what YouTube has said is that Russell
Brand's offline be they said when they
said we take offline Behavior into
account they have outright stated the
accusations against Russell Brand are
true
okay Russell Brand can now sue them and
say they're not true they're accusations
and you've made a false statement of
fact about my behavior
off off the platform
there that's a defamation per se I mean
YouTube is accusing Russell Brand of
raping women
he's got the money all you gotta do is
write a check to a lawyer and say have
at it not the lawyer do the heavy
lifting
I think you should sue for defamation I
think more people need to be creative
with their lawsuits and just Sue
fight back
v-marine says moved out to the country
came home today and found my dog Frank
passed away had to go out and bury him
please give a shout out to Frank the
Tank shout out Frank the Tank rest in
peace we hardly knew you
gravity says Rumble needs love I do give
them a fair Shake it's pretty good now
and they are working on it good progress
too Rumble gets better and better every
day we put all our videos all our Clips
are up on Rumble we use Rumble
infrastructure and uh we use parallel
economy for timcast.com that's right my
my friends if you are not a member of
timcast.com
you're missing out when you sign up not
only are you supporting the work we do
we use Rumble infrastructure and the
payment processor is actually affiliated
with Dan bongino and Rumble it's called
parallel economy it is an alternate
parallel economy payment processor we
need to support these companies more
more people need to utilize parallel
economy and that's what we do that's who
we use so uh we are trying to shore up
our defenses against cancellation by
utilizing the things that are being
built by these great individuals over at
Rumble parallel economy the work that
Dan bongino is doing we're all very very
grateful for all of this so uh get
involved man not to mention when you're
a member the Discord server I want to
give a shout out to Discord server again
because the stuff that people are doing
on the Discord server is incredible
they're hosting pre-shows after shows
they're making music now there's music
projects there's programming stuff
there's apps basically all these
like-minded individuals are networking
with each other sharing resources and
building cool stuff and you can be
involved sign up at timcast.com
just me says shout out to my husband and
his hot rod shop check out bully rods
for your custom and restoration projects
thank you for the uh Super Chat you see
for five bucks we'll shout out your
business too that's it you well there's
no guarantee we'll read everyone's
Adrian horta Martinez says Tim I can't
afford a billboard so your platform gets
my extra money Greg Abbott has yet to
acknowledge allowing terranos Houston
also known as colony Ridge be built for
illegals ran and backed by cartels I'll
keep doing this as long as my pocket
allows I I did cover that story uh
earlier the uh The Colony Ridge they
call it they're basically building a
city for illegal immigrants and they're
doing this thing where it's cash couple
hundred bucks down for a loan in a house
or like a piece of property at 15 some
ridiculous number
that's going to cause a collapse there's
gonna be people who can't have food
they're not gonna be able to afford to
eat and then you get chaos and violence
sad sad stories man
God's other son says Howard Stern is
literally everything he used to make fun
of back when he was still funny and
relevant 20 to 30 years ago
that is the case he is no longer
relevant
all right we got Ginger Mac Isaac
how do you pronounce this katamji brown
is that I pronounce her name katanji
katanji oh they put in them it needs to
recuse herself on any proposition 19
case she knows not what a woman is she
needs to step down her she's a judge and
she can't tell what a woman is that is a
massive problem how can you rely on this
person to to make decisions if they will
not decide what a woman and a man is if
they can't distinguish between the two
she needs to step down it's ferocious
this is why you know you know people say
oh Tim's silly for talking about Civil
War ladies and gentlemen When U of a
Supreme Court Justice doesn't know what
a woman is
you think this system can sustain itself
yeah I think you can I I think you like
we've got no border
it's it's just they're walking in and
the CBP is letting them in they're
building a city for these people you've
got katanji brown doesn't know what a
woman is doesn't know what a woman is
but you've got a lot of politicians who
don't either
dog come on man you get a bunch of
people who can't Define the word woman
I'm curious about their math and every
everything else and the fact of the
matter is it's not that they can't it's
that they won't yeah everybody knows and
so this this only proves that it is an
ideology that is taken hold and if we
are passing laws based on this ideology
you're basically passing laws based on a
religion yeah everybody knows right it's
this silly game that everyone is playing
it's it's it's the the emperor has no
clothes and then it goes all the way up
to the Supreme Court and the game is
still being played distill it down I
don't see how a system can function I
mean look if you owned a bar and the you
hired a manager to run the bar and the
person you hired was like I don't know
what a woman is you'd probably be like
okay well that's gonna lead to a whole
bunch of other problems with this bar I
mean like how do you deal with the
bathrooms well I don't know you think
your business is going to operate if the
dude thinks two plus two equals five if
I hired a manager he told me two plus
two is five the the register is all
wrong yeah all the accounting is all
screwed up the house going after after
Joe Biden stuff I get it like he's got
there's plenty of evidence that that
needs to be investigated and stuff but
the house should be doing everything
they can to shed light on to remind
people that she said that and get her
off the court if you cannot judge the
difference between a man and a woman you
should not be sitting on the highest
court in the land period I don't care
what anyone says this is ridiculous that
we entertain this horse this is
garbage
so my attitude is if we're at the point
where Democrats confirm someone who
doesn't know what a woman is I mean I
don't understand how you think the
system can sustain itself well I'm not
saying it's gonna like it's the
apocalypse like it's just going to
crumble and break apart right and we
will have to start repairing it yeah
it's gonna it's gonna crumble very very
uh slowly and for a very long time and
think about the USSR existed for uh 80
plus years with the biggest power on the
planet Earth opposing them at every pass
once America goes down that road and
there's nobody opposing uh what's
happening I mean how long can can
something like that sustain it'll just
it'll be a slow degradation but for
decades and decades and decades I just
don't think there's going to be a a
major shock unless there's you know what
we're what we're seeing happen right now
which is the cyber attacks the Cyber
pandemic that they've uh oh yeah cyber
911 huh yeah that's there that's they're
referring to the wazir says the media
going after bran for the promiscuity
they cheered sounds like whistleblowers
reporting Scientology forces members to
confess every little misstep so the
church has all the black male material
they'll Ever Need
well I mean I think it's funny that
they celebrate Russell Brand they all
laugh he tells these jokes now 20 years
later they're like nah you're a wrong
thinker
spark says Garland testified today under
oath that the doj is investigating
parents for school board meetings based
on reports from the media of course they
are because they're evil because they
are evil evil people
I I look
I said it earlier there are people who
are like it's getting really dangerous
when people refer to their political
opponents as evil
the the doj is going after parents for
issuing formal complaints at school
board meetings they have arrested Donald
Trump's lawyers they threw two old
ladies in prison for 11 years these
women are in this in their 70s they
threw them in prison for 11 years
because they protested uh they sat in
front of him yeah they said because
because they were sitting in front of an
exit where at a Planned Parenthood oh
right because they were protesting
abortion right they were they were they
were using their First Amendment right
to protest and because they were in
front of the the exit or whatever they
go to jail for 11 years put them in jail
for the rest of their life
I mean come on let's even take a take a
step back right as a father of four kids
I have the government
telling me I have to inject my kids with
something that we know nothing about
that is evil we got this from NY bsfp
Tim you summed it up perfectly Howard
Stern was always on the side of evil he
hasn't changed right
that's what he does
yeah
what do we have
our Valera says she misunderstood the
gesture it wasn't a grope he was trying
to choke her Homer Simpson's style
because she's so annoying
but I guess that's technically groping
too I don't know
wretched Redemption music says new album
Alpha Omega out now Spotify and iTunes
Rolling Stone mag calls it the anthem
for right-wing conspiracy Tim calls it a
reverse kickflip I have no idea what
that means but uh rolling stone called
it an Anthem for writing conspiracy
there you go
congratulations garbage yes
just leave me alone says Cassidy
Hutchinson said Trump choked at a secret
service agent then grabbed the steering
wheel not Rudy grouter and put his hand
under her now Rudy grew up here and put
Hannah's under her skirt in a full tent
of people behind the stage sounds like a
romance novel
and and look you've got a combination of
people who will they don't care if it's
true or not they'll just keep repeating
it because they're evil
they're evil people sorry man that's
just that's just reality they lie all
the time NBC news said Ray Epps was seen
trying to calm people down and stop them
from storming the capital
I think that was yeah NBC he was later
seen trying to calm down the the rioters
what he's on camera
storming the front line with everybody I
can't wait until we find out the
specific detail about Ray apps I mean
yeah we've all got these type but I mean
I want to know like I want to read
emails I want to see see all of this in
its Glory yeah there's um the charging
document is that he pleaded guilty so
the full breakdown of his sentencing
guidelines are the request explains what
he did and the funny thing is the
document they released
basically is one of the most serious
documents of any of the j6ers like
talking about how he was on the front
line how he's whispering and then the
men charged the barricades and rip him
down how he's telling people to go in
and he got charged with one count yeah
one misdemeanor and honestly the most
suspicious thing out of all of it is the
way the media is covering for him when
they are completely you know destroying
any other j6 uh participant so you know
if you weren't suspicious before the
media started covering for him that
should at least make you ask questions
Joseph says who wants to be a part of
this culture Tim what good does it
really offer Boomers only care about
growing tomatoes and hunting the
youngsters are having a rough go no one
is happy
let me explain
when you build culture what you are
basically saying is hey
I'm doing cool things that are fun would
you like to do cool things that are fun
with me we will then trade with each
other and build wealth and then we'll be
happy and comfortable building culture
is not getting involved in politics and
voting and going knocking on doors
that's politicking culture building
means that when all these young people
are miserable and doing nothing with
their lives and they're singing their
basements withering away you are having
a blast you are eating good food and you
are with your friends and your family
and you are successful and then if it
all hits the fan and crumbles you will
have a community of people around you
that will help you survive that's
building culture
so if you don't want to do it well you
know get a dog go live in the woods
buy a river and fish and enjoy life you
know just life what did you make of it
man all these people are so miserable
but life is just what it is everybody
everybody wants something
you know you got to be you got to be the
master of your own domain
where are we at we'll grab some more
Super chats
what is this one
all right Weber J says I watched Russell
Brand's master class on recover in the
12-step program he speaks a lot about
turning away from worldly pleasures and
instead serving and getting back in
touch with God very interesting
interesting Russell Brand
we'll grab uh we got a good one here
the duck abides says hey Tim in Illinois
they passed a law that allows migrants
to become police officers on a side note
with our assault weapons ban it exempts
police from the Law's restrictions this
implies a non-citizen migrant can own a
semi-auto rifle and we can't
yes it does
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends and head
over to timcast.com click join us as a
member you'll get access to the
uncensored members only show which will
be live in just a few minutes you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast Harrison
you want to shout anything out uh sure
yeah
band.videoinfowars.com infowars.com
show is how you watch us on the American
Journal each and every weekday morning 8
to 11 A.M you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram Harrison H Smith on
Twitter Harrison Hill Smith on Instagram
and I have a tick tock too so Smith
I live in Southern California I got a
restaurant there called calico fish
house it's in Huntington Beach
California if you're hurting and you
don't have the money to buy yourself a
meal stop in say that you heard this on
Tim cast and the meals on me wow very
nice you got Twitter or anything you
want to shout out yep uh it's at Andrew
gruel on X and on Instagram at Chef girl
right on
I am Phil that remains on X I am Phil it
remains official on Instagram the band
is all the remains you can follow us on
Spotify Apple music Amazon music uh
Pandora YouTube you know the internet
still working on my outro but uh we got
some songs coming out you can follow
those they'll be at uh youtube.com
timcast songs follow trashhouse records
also and if you want to follow me
personally I'm at Carter banks on X I
guess and Carter banks4l on Instagram
for a nope we will see you all over at
timcast.com in just a few minutes thanks
for hanging out